Oh,
one second.
My, my, boo!
Thank you so much.
Hello, everybody.
Hi.
Hi, hi.
Welcome in.
Welcome back.
Half-Life 2.
Boy, golly, has it been a while since the last time I
touched this game?
um half a life maybe
half a life oh my gosh a fate explored thank you so much for
that thank you captain thank you thank you plus twos i'm
seeing more plus twos than minus two plus two plus two great
to see you at tokumi even if If you rejected me, you were
still very cute.
Can't wait for the future.
Thank you for existing in Vicky Rito.
Um, Miss Fist, uh, I, I happen to know that you said, Hey,
Minky, in my checky, can you be pouting instead?
You are changing.
You are trying to rewrite a history.
I know for a very...
I was there.
I am a witness.
You said to me, Hey, Minky.
Can you, pal?
Give my checky?
Fabricated story.
The Ochi call out is real.
I...
I state to the judge and the jury...
I know!
I was there!
Well, can you, pal?
I...
I said...
Fine.
I said fine.
I will not entertain your heart hand.
I do not even thumbs up it.
I reject it.
I deny.
I deny it!
And so I did.
And so...
I did also use the T-note.
There I go!
For the...
Don't know.
I don't know what it will come through because of all the...
Uh...
Gifted memberships.
Docomira present.
Have fun with the stream.
I've seen the check-in where it was so amazing.
Thank you!
I heard rejection.
Yeah, deny.
Denied.
Ugh.
All day I've been packing, packing, packing.
And now everything is dusty.
I picked up my socks on the floor and there was a spider
underneath.
I was so scared.
I was terrified.
Hey, Mintard, you needed a free Supa.
Where did you hear that?
Jacob?
Thank you very much for the super chat.
Ghost Cuity, thank you so much for that.
That's what he gave to take you.
Oh, Amito and I was like you.
I was gonna come up with some half-life pun, but instead I
just wanted to tell you I got Taco Bell because I thought of
Amito.
Oh, yeah!
Wait, what'd you get?
Did you remember how to say apple jump?
Huh?
The spider's home is moving too.
Are you taking them with you?
Actually, I think my maid dress... So I have a maid for
those who don't know.
dress that I hang on my wall for decoration.
And, um, I think it might be the last thing I touch, because
I think it's so full of spiders.
I don't want to...
I'm so scared!
I don't...
It's still...
Like, things are off my wall.
Minus, I have some...
I probably can take these down.
I have some, like, things for...
pat like padding on the wall to help with insulation or like
you know sound and stuff
but basically everything's down but the matrix rain of
spiders i don't say but sometimes on stream i just see one
leave the dress i don't say but sometimes i just see one
leave and i'm like Here it goes.
Miss Melchan, welcome back!
Oh my gosh, 25 months.
Thank you.
Good morning, Ninto!
I'm closing in on Unk status today.
Would you mind if I ask for a quick...
Birthday wish!
Maple, happy birthday!
That's your birthday!
Wait, what does...
Wait, oh, wait.
I give you a wish?
To wish?
Or do you have a wish?
You shouldn't say your wishes.
Wait, do you...
Wait, I think you should wish for less spiders.
No, actually spiders are good for the environment.
I think you should wish for...
But don't tell anybody, because then it might not come true.
I think you should wish for a delicious cake or drink.
Both!
Be greedy, it's your birthday.
That is what I think you should birthday wish.
Hey, that's my wish.
Don't tell anybody.
No, not delicious spiders.
You guys are getting it mixed up.
Good luck on episode 4, me, though.
I'm so happy to finally have time for a full Mickey stream.
You are a half-life savior after a long day of
overstimulation.
Uh-oh.
Oh, um, yeah, but the game might be overstimulating, though.
It's not my birthday.
Beefy five-layer burrito.
Oh, I'm hungry.
Actually, I'm not so hungry.
Why did I say that?
Thank you, Minto.
I will wish for spiders and cake today, but separate.
Not together.
Maybe we can wish for all the spiders to be outside.
Did you have girl dinner?
No!
I think after, though, I'll have a hummus and crackers for
dinner, I think.
I want carrots, though.
Maybe I'll go get some carrots.
Unless somebody wants to offer them.
I would gladly...
Except, do carrots give anybody else hiccups?
When I eat carrots, I always get hiccups for some reason.
I looked it up.
Maybe there was something wrong with me.
And...
I guess...
I guess the way I eat carrots is wrong.
Because, like...
I suck in too much air or something.
Hey there, Minto, it's good to see you.
Hello, Maddie!
Thank you so much for the...
Superchat.
You know, there are horse girls.
And then there are horse girls.
I'm the latter, you know, they're like, you know, someone
that's just like, yeah, I'm a horse girl.
I love horses, I ride horses, it's not, and then there's a
horse girl.
I want spiders inside to protect me from flies.
Well, okay, we can wish all the spiders to go to Rook's
house.
But don't tell anybody.
Money's for the Oishi Ningen.
Oh, thank you.
Currently playing original Turok trilogy, I'm on the third
game, it's definitely not best of three.
Oh, if you ever need a Doom, like about dynos and monsters.
Dino, wait, there is a new dinosaur game, hold on, there's a
new like dinosaur horror game coming out.
I saw it today.
Oh, hold on, I saved it.
It's like a co-op.
But I'm, of course, I'm interested.
Two years!
Magister Tagu!
Here's my free carrots for you.
Oh!
Pick up.
We're moving on this from this too quickly.
Are you like gasping for air while eating carrots?
I don't know!
I think I just get very excited about eating carrots.
Because I really love them.
That I'm like...
And so...
I...
I end up getting hiccups because of it.
This is just...
It's something I always noticed.
And I recently looked it up because I was like, there's no
way that every time I eat carrots, I get hiccups.
I don't understand.
Yeah, we'll protect each other.
Spiders to Rook's house.
Spiders are our friends.
They eat bug retubers.
But they don't eat cockroaches.
That's what I need gone.
That's the one bug I need out of my afterlife.
Don't you like cut the carrots?
No.
They're baby carrots.
I hate that I have to go to a normie birthday in the middle
of this.
Not the normie birthday.
This is not my favorite Half-Life segment.
But I know you can do it.
for my future Cuban sandwich.
Enjoy your 2000's rebel girlfriend date.
We're going on a date?
Oh my gosh.
Have fun at the birthday party!
Bonimiento.
Are you sure you're not a hamster?
I also hiccup while eating carrots.
I've never met someone else.
What's wrong with us, Kalma?
Carrots are for eating, not inhaling.
I can't help it.
I'm so sorry.
She's the Umami-Minto pretty ghost VTuber.
Next outfit is Minto Bunny Girl Senpai.
Maybe.
Bunny Girl outfit.
Hmm.
I'd like one.
I think it'd be fun.
I want some carrots now.
Episode 1 is relatively short.
I believe in the one stream, Minto.
Babe!
Thank you, Munchie!
I will do my best.
Oh, wait.
I was looking up that, um, that game.
Hold on.
Apparently there's also, we, there's a Halloween game coming
out.
I don't know anything about it.
But also, after Friday, they have some big shoes to fill
after we lost Friday the 13th.
Guys, I want to play the new...
Oh, it came through.
I want to play the new Super Massive Dark Pictures game.
Directive 80-20.
Directive 8008.
Directive boob.
I heard it's not very good.
I asked, I DMed Nimi if she would play with me.
But, I know she's, she's, she's, uh, she's away.
But, um.
It's fun with friends, but solo is mad.
Oh, really?
It looks funny.
Oh, I want to play.
Oh, my gosh.
I love these games so much.
I can't get enough of them.
They're so janky and they're so goofy.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, Instinction is the name.
Instinction is a prehistoric survival horror game that
serves as a spiritual successor to Dino Crisis, which is
kind of insane.
It features monsters, or not monsters, sorry, dinosaurs.
Why did I say encounters and atmospheric exploration across
a lush...
Wait, I know crisis is cool.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know about that.
But, yeah.
I don't know.
I just liked a list that was like, here's some new horror
co-op games coming out.
There's also a new fears to fathom game coming in.
out.
That is also co-op.
For some reason?
Fierce de Fathom first ever co-op game.
But I asked Doki to play it with me.
well, we will be playing that together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She said yeah.
Yeah, she said yes.
Twice the horror.
Hmm.
So probably, I don't know.
We'll see how Nemi feels.
I don't want to put pressure on her or anything, obviously.
I say it because...
Well, maybe I should say nothing until she reads it.
I don't want anyone being like, Hey, Mint asked you if you
want to play this game.
Don't do that.
If she doesn't want to play, that's A-OK.
Maybe because, you know, some people want to play it solo or
something.
Too late.
Now!
The Doki play the other Fears of Fathom games.
I have no idea.
Honestly, they're like episodic, so I don't think you need
to.
But I'm just curious how it will be co-op.
I have no idea.
Have you ever played Metal Gear Solid V?
I have.
Just not on this channel.
Yeah, so...
Those are some things, some upcoming things.
Yes.
I'm trying to figure out...
So basically, when I move, I'm going to have to not be able
to use my big computer, my normal computer for a bit.
So I'm going to be on my travel, my travel potato PC.
So I'm trying to find things that I can play, you know what
I mean?
that I can stream and not break the PC.
I love the chemistry between you indie VTubers.
For some reason, I read that as you and indie VTubers.
I was like, wait, I am indie.
You got Switch games.
Yeah, yeah, we will probably have more Switch games.
Oh, wait, though.
Yes, I'll just have to figure out a way to capture it.
No, I can capture it.
Yeah, yeah, I have a travel capture.
Okay, yes.
The Switch games.
Um, but jumping from that, uh, we'll try to get through,
well, we should, uh, we'll get through episode one today.
Fingies crossed.
Um, sad news.
I don't think my ear infection is gone.
My ear is itchy.
So let's play the game so I can get these earbuds out of my
ears.
Actually, let me switch to my headphones.
Let me switch to my big headphones and stuff.
It's about three hours.
Oh, easy peasy.
Easy, easy peasy.
It doesn't hurt.
It just itch.
Which is maybe even more annoying.
Maybe more annoying than it hurting.
Well, I don't know.
I wanted to recommend Scale the Deep, a pixel art fishing
game.
That's pretty fun and short.
It's been my obsession lately.
Fishing.
You got games on your phone?
Greetings, Mrs. Freakman.
Mrs. Mrs. Who is the other half?
Wish an hour's fishing.
But yeah, it's been a long time since I played Half-Life 2,
so some people were saying that Half-Life 2 Episode 1.
Why did they name it like this?
It's so confusing.
is uh kind of eases you back into the game so me me snake
awesome live
going to be an episodic thing cool cool cool orca yeah orca
but let's get into it then cool with the sounds i guess we
New game?
Oh.
Oh, spoilers?
Can I recommend a cool spooky indie game, Eclipseium?
What's it about, Gappa?
Florida's just looking at it like any other day.
It was looking very deadly premonition.
I'm not gonna lie.
Tell me, Dr. Freeman, if you can.
You have destroyed so much.
What is it exactly that you have created?
Can you name even one thing?
I thought not.
I created...
Oh.
That's a good question.
What?
What do I do?
Oh, we blew that up?
Yes, I remember.
Blah, rah, rah.
Are they thanking us or...
You're a theoretical physicist.
Whoa, whoa, no, they're getting Alex!
Oh my god!
Booty shot, booty shot.
So they're like, thank you.
Save her, not me.
That's fine.
Yeah, they're thanking you, yeah.
And they're shaming him.
They hate this guy.
about that they hate g-man because he and i remember he like
enslaved them no
and they're upset they were like we don't want to we don't
want to be we don't want to be bad yeah and so we saved them
my health is 47.
oh hello Dog!
Dog!
Gordon!
I was so worried.
Yeah, you got saved and I didn't.
Hey, the gravity gun.
Give it to him, dog.
Oh, alright.
Oh, thank you.
There, Gordon.
Dog, happy to see you.
I can tell.
Dog, dog!
Launch object, grab object.
he was so sure I wouldn't find you here so we took out
everything and then I still don't know how we got out of
there the last thing I remember is brain falling huge
explosion and then I heard vortigons next thing I knew dog
was digging me out of the rubble oh it's all so strange well
we should oh it's my my dad we've been trying to reach him
for hours dog seems pretty bad up there wait I can't hold on
oh soup soup soup okay I got I gotta use my brain to get up
there.
Okay, hold on.
Oh shoot.
One second.
It's been like a hot second since I, okay.
Wait, is there anything for even me to use?
Hmm.
Oh, I see.
Wait.
Ah, there we go.
Oh.
Wait, it landed on me and now I'm stuck.
Wait.
Guys, I'm soft-locked through the tutorial.
Oh, okay, we're fine.
You may not remember, but Dr. Britton mentioned Gordon's
contract with GMM being open to the highest bidder.
The Vordagans had other plans, fortunately.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
remember that?
Yes.
I completely forgot we're fighting Neil Breen.
He has a new movie out, Neil Breen.
Dad.
Are you there?
Alex?
Alex.
Come in.
Hold on a sec.
There's so much interference.
Oh, man.
These are these COVID Zoom 2020 calls.
Yeah, apparently he does.
I saw him tweet about it.
Hold to the right.
There we go.
Hold it there.
We got it.
Very good.
I remember saving you from the prison.
Oh, we're like literally in downtown.
Hi, hi, hi, hi.
Listen, you two have to get out of the city.
The Citadel could blow at any moment.
There's no question that it will, I'm afraid.
Our remote sensors indicate the process is accelerating
toward a dark energy flare.
Anyone left in the vicinity will be subjected to energetic
events.
Just put a little crack in it and it'll fizzle out.
All of your intros are amazing.
The animation of you and a hot dog costume on the Mokas.
Thank you!
Oh dear, Eli, I'm sorry, but surely there's no need for
undue alarm.
Alex is well out of harm's way by now.
Well, actually, we're still at the Citadel.
Oh, dear.
But there's really no time.
The core is exceedingly close to collapse.
Why, there's no way to get far enough without verse...
Well, nothing short of a direct intervention in the core
could possibly retard the reaction.
going in into the core yes oh but it's far too dangerous to
consider the chamber will be bathed in radiation you do have
the hazard suit if we found a way into the citadel it's
possible but I agree why don't we just leave what's the
what's the problem with leaving what's the problem with us
going and and leaving I It's in my job.
Promise me that you won't take a blow before they leave.
Will it?
I promise.
I love you.
Don't worry.
I'll see you soon.
I don't think we'd be too slow if we got on dogs back, I'm
just saying.
Me too.
Let's see if we can find a way into the Citadel from
somewhere along the rim.
Okay.
Hmm.
She mad I didn't sign up for this.
I just got back to napkin.
Yeah.
Thank you for the super chats, you guys.
Thank you.
Okay, boy.
Pack up and meet us on the far side of this ridge.
Pack up.
It's going to explode.
Oh, oops.
What a drop.
I didn't mean to do that.
Oh.
I already did it.
Okay, there's stuff here.
What is this stuff?
Oh!
Sorry.
Holy cow!
I thought it was...
I thought it was loot!
Alright, here I go.
Do you need help?
Oh.
Good job.
Uh...
Is there something down there?
Holy cow.
What are you looking at?
Alex can handle herself.
Yeah, she's very independent and cool.
I can't tell where she wants me to do.
What do you want me to do?
She's like, I'm just gonna look pretty.
I don't think I can do...
I don't think I can do it on...
Oh, I can do it on the car!
Just kidding.
She's fine.
Dog!
Oh my god.
Oh my
god, dog!
Dog, answer us!
Oh my gosh.
You scared the hell out of me.
Now stay with us.
You're the one who told him to separate!
You're the one that was just like, okay dog, you do that
thing and I'll, uh, you know.
going to be easy.
No.
Well, dog, what do you think?
Any ideas?
What the dog doing?
Dog has many ideas.
What does...
You're going to launch us over there, yeah.
There has to be a way to get across.
But how?
How, indeed.
I was going to say, what about the water?
Why?
Maybe dog is more monkey.
No g-men allowed, only the og-men.
OG means og-side ghost.
Ah!
Dog!
That was actually close.
I'm trying to get this.
Oh, wait a minute.
Oops.
You're not serious.
Are you?
The whole sequence is a display of...
Sorry, I'm trying to like pay attention to...
Thank you!
Entrico, thank you so much for the 20 minutes.
Thank you for the super chat!
Speak up?
I want you to get out of here as fast as you can.
Go find Dad.
We'll catch up.
Don't worry.
Oh!
Big hug.
Dog hug.
What about, okay, let's all come in?
All right, me next!
Me next!
Me next?
Dog.
Dog, I'm also risking my life here.
Oh.
Okay, Gordon, get in.
No hug for Gordon.
This is so sad.
There we go.
Oh, this feels like a video game ride.
Okay, dog.
Let's do it.
Before I change my...
At least put on your seatbelt.
Careful, hold on.
Phew.
Good throw, dog!
Now go, boy.
Go on.
You'll be fine.
Just...
Uh-oh.
Wait, did I say video game?
I meant like a ride.
Wait.
Like, you know, like a, you know, like a 3D, 4D ride or
something.
Ah!
Like Spider-Man.
You said video game ride.
Oh.
You know what I mean?
Like a theme park ride.
Oh, you good?
All right, let's get off before the next ride starts.
That was crazy.
Get me out of here?
All right.
Holy crap.
Oh my god, that could have been us.
Oh, oh, whoa, where'd that go from?
Oh, good thing you have a gun because I have nothing.
And I am scared because of it.
I have nothing.
Wee!
Yeah, so we should do this fast and leave, right?
Oh, I forgot about these.
The part where you get water sprayed at you and the chain
swivel in front of a massive TV screen?
Yes?
This is on the...
Do I have a flag?
Okay, good.
Oh.
Freaky music.
Ambedave!
Thank you so much!
For that cause I'm up!
Same.
Oh, was that a... was that bodies or...
Oh, was that guy twirling?
Oh, she didn't... she didn't see.
That's fine.
Honestly, maybe for the best.
Okay, we don't want to go that way.
We should go this way.
yeah follow me follow me if you want to live do i know where
i'm going no do i need to oh oh there's like what is that
stalkers stalkers they shouldn't bother us if we leave them
alone i don't he doesn't like wait why are you doing that oh
okay hey wait can I grab one at what it what just oh my
power I forgot about it yeah what if we no don't punch him I
don't What's a roller mine?
I'm going through?
What's this?
Is that a person?
Wait!
Sorry.
Wrong button.
My bad.
Well, he is dead.
Is this it?
Is this a roller mine?
Not a roller mine.
Oh, man.
Ah!
Ouch.
Can you find where those roller mines are going?
I slipped.
That's okay.
Where the roller mines are going.
Okay.
Well, that is a roller mine.
It's just maybe not an active one, I suppose.
Wait.
Actually, I have no idea.
Look, it's a tight little corner.
Alright, guys.
What are these guys?
Have I seen these guys before?
stalker but i don't feel like i recognize him at all you
know
briefly like once in the first game oh they were in the
background we want the falling cyber pug soccer ball yes yes
yes i see
very nice oh what is that what is that now oh it's a little
janky a little...
Hold on, maybe we can jump on there.
Ouch!
What goes up here?
Ah!
Oh, I activated this somehow.
Okay.
Sweet, sweet suit juice.
Crab!
Wait.
Maybe it's in a tube.
Grab!
Okay, yeah.
We'll go get the one from over there, I suppose.
I'll jump, I guess?
Maybe that will work.
I need to press the button.
Yeah, I get that.
Okay.
Put!
We're fine.
Ah!
Maybe we go this way.
Wait.
Does it matter?
Oh shoot.
Look out.
This is fine, everybody.
This is fine.
You'll need a way back.
Yeah!
How about that?
Oh, this is a platform.
Okay, maybe...
What if I, like, take one and...
I don't think I can launch it up there.
What if I pressed it really fast and it dropped only one?
Could it do that, I wonder.
Oh, my suit power.
Yes, thank you.
I forgot about that.
Yes.
Delicious.
Okay.
Oh shoot, they all come at once?
They all come at once?
Oh!
Wow!
Can I grab?
Where'd it go?
Wait, how did I get hurt?
Yeah, I think they all rolled away.
Elevator bonged, man.
Jeez, Louise, am I made of paper?
Okay.
Alright, let's try that again.
And we'll grab one.
Oh, shoot.
Oh!
Okay.
Anyway, now this way I don't have to waste, uh, you know.
I don't have to waste energy and stuff like that.
Be careful.
Watch your, mind your head.
Mind your head.
Off to a good star, absolutely.
Okay.
Wow, that thing like healed me twice over though.
Okay, alright, grab one.
We'll wait for this to go back down or...
Okay, now!
Uh, how do I get back up?
wait uh wait how oh oh the elevator I'm such a dummy dumb oh
but he cannot okay uh oh maybe I get rid of this guy and
grab this
oh shoot wait uh shoot oh shoot wait don't explode it's fine
we took just a a pinch of Ah!
No!
Okay, we tried that again.
Why did he drop it?
I was so stinking.
Okay, okay.
Alright, now I...
Okay, we'll wait for it.
One more time.
We got plenty of time, don't you worry your pretty little
head about it.
Okay.
Wait!
Go, go, go, go!
Yep!
Easy!
Easiest task I've ever had.
A little extra juice in the right spot, and it's on our
side.
This is endless comedy.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Okay.
There it is.
Oh, thank goodness.
But when a plan comes together, oh never mind.
Oh, what is quick save again?
That's right.
Oh, dang.
We'll come back to Half-Life.
Remember your quick save and quick load powers.
Was it F5?
No?
F6.
Okay.
F6 is a quick save.
Everybody's saying F5 was literally trying to sabotage me.
You guys are evil.
This guy was not pressing nothing.
It's all broken.
That's just a robot.
Robots don't care about us, right?
I can't tell.
F5 was a screenshot key in other games.
It can be the save key.
on other games.
Well, definitely...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no!
Oh, my...
What do you mean?
They're too busy preparing!
What happened to them?
I need you up front, girl.
I have no weapon.
I think you don't understand.
What is that?
Oh.
My bad.
Uh oh.
Oh wait, where'd the other guys go?
Oh, I guess they ran through here?
Maybe?
Excuse me.
Yeah, you in front, Alex.
You in front.
You in front, Alex.
Yep.
Sorry.
Come
here.
I grab you with my powers.
Well, that was random.
Lol, so random.
Talk about unstable.
I really don't think we should hang around.
Yeah, me neither.
That was random.
This entire place is coming apart and you, that's your
commentary.
Oh, here.
What is that?
Oh, F6.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, so I guess it's F6 and then F7 is...
Oh.
Alex!
There's many people coming!
Oh, okay, we're fine.
We gotta cross through that.
I'll be right behind.
F7 is load.
Okay.
Oh.
Be right behind me.
Great.
Alright, here we go.
I'm sprinting.
Nice, we made it.
Alex?
lore super stalkers are humans transformed into those things
basically mindless organless things that are wow this is a
great shot they're basically nothing but workers with laser
beams awesome one can only hope they don't remember their
past human lives Felix thank you so much for the pink and
for the lore thank you it was the 2000s Josh Whedon was the
height of which Who's that?
We made it!
We're not gonna make it!
Okay, we're running to where all these soldiers were coming
from, so I'm a little nervous.
What's going on over here?
What went on in here?
What?
Stop pushing, Peanut.
Creator of Buffy the Vampire.
Oh, okay, we're going down.
What the hell are those things?
Hold on, I didn't get to explore over here.
Oh.
Console is useful information.
Wait.
Let me see if I can pin down a path to the core.
Okay.
He popularized, well, that just happened.
Oh, Breen!
This guy!
I will show you and set the relay elsewhere.
There's no way I can survive that burned.
Thank God it's just an old recording.
The host body must be joking.
I can't move past it.
What are we saying?
That's what it takes.
Just hurry, he's right behind me.
He's all right behind me, isn't he?
The cut is so funny.
What the hell?
Uh oh.
Wait, what does that mean?
Oh!
What the hell?
Huh?
Oh.
We woke the baby from the nap?
What is this guy?
Oh my god, my eyes.
What the hell was that thing?
Half-life movie with the old brain.
I took mental damage, for real.
That was terrible.
It went upstairs.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, no!
What's going on in there?
I'm too slow!
Oh, if I try to...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
No!
Oh, no!
Wait!
I didn't mean to throw that.
Oh!
It's doing something to the gravity gun.
Oh.
Like it did in Brink's portal reactor.
Oh, that's right.
I can take out anything now, right?
Yeah, I will.
Because this is like now...
Like, crazy...
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, oh, no.
Okay.
Oh, geez.
Uh-huh.
What?
Okay.
I saw things flying through the air.
Oh, there it is.
We need to get across here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, we can grab people now.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, can I...
You good?
That was fine.
Do I need to like...
Okay, there we go.
Nice thinking.
Yep.
Please don't...
Let's sprint.
You know what?
Ah!
Sorry.
You scared me.
Oh my god.
Hey!
Ouch.
You're welcome.
Are they coming from...
Go away.
Oh, gosh.
I almost zapped you!
Oh.
Nope.
She's got them.
Wait, where'd they go?
Oh, I didn't do that.
Wait, who did that?
That wasn't me.
Did you?
How'd you do that?
I'm off by I apologize in advance for your eyes.
I mean, you can do the same cover fire in short bursts.
Crouch to be accurate.
Reload often.
Thank you, Resident Glitchface.
Have fun!
Okay, where do we go?
Maybe that way?
Oh, yeah, we can't go this way, so we gotta go.
Let's see.
Can I...
Let's grab one from over here, maybe at least.
Oh, wait, what's over this way?
Anything?
I'm exploring?
Nothing to explore.
Yeah, Alex.
Alex has a gun, but that does not launch people into the
air, if I'm mistaken.
Shoot.
Hey, mister, can you go grab that for me?
Oh, he evaporated.
Wait, what's this?
Just a light?
fancy uh this hmm oh there's there's some down there okay
there we go
where is he where is he where is he oh
okay good job Alex good job Alex sorry I almost left him
alive.
Okay, good job.
Good job team.
I think.
That doesn't sound so good.
All right, uh, why are they, why are you even focusing on
us?
Why are you even concerned about us at the moment?
Oh.
Did I grab that?
Hmm, okay.
Ooh.
Oh no!
Wait.
Okay, there's one.
Oink.
Oh, so close.
A little bit.
Electric light in the video game is the same as an electric
light in the real world.
Really?
What if I go on this side?
Can I get it in through there?
Oh!
Make it without me!
I mean, you're not wrong.
An electric light in a video game is basically like an
electric light.
Watch out!
Alex!
It's like one in the real world, yeah.
I'll make it in there.
Oh!
You can just zap fools if you don't feel like grabbing them.
Oh, is it that just with left click?
Oh!
Wait, what?
Oh, oh, oh, watch out for the fire that just nearly fell on
my head!
Okay!
That's fine!
Sure!
There we go.
Hug the wall.
We made it.
Sorry.
Do
I step in it or?
Is that unwise?
Nah, it's fine.
Oh my gosh.
I zapped him.
Famous horror game Half-Life 2.
Actually, though?
She's so calm.
She is so calm and cool and clear.
Oh, I think we got to jump here.
So be careful.
Stone cold.
Behind you.
I can't reach him.
Oh!
Whoa.
Wait, what did it do?
You blocked my view?
Oh.
Whoa indeed, I also saw a tripod guy down there.
I'm a little...
Halix, I'm a little nervous.
No, she backs up!
She hates me!
No, please, I'm asking for some...
For some reassurance.
I'm asking for some...
For a little mental support here.
I need to open that up.
She's really good at pushing me out of the way.
Chat's frozen.
I will fix it.
Sorry about that.
Thank you for letting me know.
I don't know why I'm lagging.
I have no idea why I'm lagging at all.
That's strange.
Yeah, I'm lagging actually quite crazy.
How?
Why?
Hmm.
I thought I noticed it earlier.
Wallpaper engine?
This game is like a million years old.
I'll stop it though.
No?
Even then, I'm still lagging.
Why do game characters just throw magazines to their guns on
the ground?
Because it's fine.
Huh.
Hmm.
Lower mouse sensitivity?
I don't think so.
Not for graphics norm.
Hmm.
It's the FPS capped.
Should be.
Let me double check.
Alex does not need a hug right now.
You need to hug the wall for comfort.
Let's see.
Video?
There is no FPS.
Oh, this is under advanced.
I don't even remember.
I don't even think I touched any of these.
Hmm.
It's actually one day before Half-Life 2 Episode 1's release
date, 20 years ago.
No kidding!
Wait, that's crazy.
Oh, V-Sync?
Wait, where was it?
Do you guys see it?
Was it on?
Wait, I don't see it.
Did you guys see it?
Wait, that's crazy timing.
Oh!
V-Sync, disable, let's try.
I guess I look a bit better.
Still laggy.
Yeah, still laggy.
I don't remember if I had this issue with the game before.
Hmm.
Oh my gosh, in chat, it froze again too.
What the heck?
Everything is so cursed.
Oh, I don't have anything else running.
I don't have anything else running.
That's so weird, though.
This game is actually 20 years old.
It shouldn't be, like, hitting me so hard.
Weird.
Hmm.
It gives you more of a ghost-like movement.
I'm here to be spooked, baby.
I didn't see an FPS cap either.
Oh well.
Please stop saying it's 20.
It hurts.
That's just so strange though.
Sorry, I guess it'll be just a little janky.
It's dusty in here.
I know it just saves, but I'm also scared.
And it makes me...
When it saves, or like when it loads to a new area, That
makes me want to save.
You know what I mean?
Wait, doesn't this...
Isn't this a teleporter or something?
Or am I crazy?
What is this thing?
Looks like this could be a transport elevator to the core.
Very cool.
Oh.
Okay, get up.
I got rid of the garbage, my lady.
Oh, do I need to put it in there?
Okay.
Did you shoot?
What was that?
Okay, I'm working on it.
Garbage day.
Oh, look up.
Ah!
Oh, Alex?
Oh, I need to do something about it.
Oh, okay.
Oh my god, the bodies!
Oh my god!
That stuff's fine, right?
Heads up!
My god!
What's wrong with this lift?
Can you get it going again?
Oh, sure.
I can?
Yes, pretty miss.
Whatever you say.
Watch your head.
How do I get in there?
Oh,
watch your head.
Watch your head.
You could push Alex into the vertical combine ballpost with
enough coaxing.
I saw the back rooms movie today and I like it.
I want to see it so bad.
I heard really good things about it.
I cannot tell what is like an opening into this room.
So where I cannot tell where I need to shoot it, you know?
Maybe over there.
Oh, that's a wall.
All right, that's a window.
I thought it was quite good.
I want to see it.
Right hand side is open.
Oh, so maybe like if I go like there.
Oh.
Alex?
Oh, you're still alive.
Ah!
I'm going to turn down the sound effects.
Just a teeny time.
Literally the cutest goober.
Stop it.
Above the console, like right there.
That's what I was.
was thinking but I feel like it's just gonna launch back at
us no it's also very hard to see yeah see do I need to jump
somewhere I don't think I can I don't know if I can unless
oh wait oh
oh I see oh wait oh gosh that scared me Okay, look up.
Very cool.
Up there!
Start her up again, Morty.
Do what you did last time.
Alex, can you say something?
Sooner!
The next time!
Please!
Can you say something?
A little...
A little sooner.
I can't believe I've been subbed almost two years.
I can't believe either.
Thank you.
Oh, no way chat is frozen again.
If it freezes one more time, we're just going to ignore it,
guys.
Sorry.
There's nothing I can do about it.
Actually, I'll try refreshing.
Let me try this.
But I can only do what I can do.
I don't want to keep pausing the game to fix it It's a
YouTube, it's not me Chats overrated No, I like you guys
This game is designed to run on the finest hardware that
2006 could provide Your modern machine just can't do it
Wanna know what's funnier than 24 25 Wayfamers, there we go
Game caught you lot Looking up Man Oh, all right, why are
there so many of these?
Wait!
Oh, so close.
We almost had it.
Wait!
Oh, wait, did it just leave the...
Why are you making that face for her?
Girl, she isn't perpetually rolling her eyes.
Oh.
Sorry.
Do you have a problem, Alex?
Do you have something that you want to...
Do you have something you want to say to me?
Huh?
Are you... Do you have something that you want to... Do you
want to solve this?
Do you want the gun instead of me?
I'll happily provide it for you.
Wait, how did that not go in?
Hoi!
Wait, why is it not going in?
She backs up.
She really hates me, you guys.
She's giving you that Minto look of scorn.
That did what's LMDQ!
Thank you so much.
Oh, it's backwards.
Is it?
Oh, I couldn't really tell.
Oh.
Destroy, destroy!
Destroy, destroy the whole console!
Mmm soup!
Oh!
Wait!
Did something just fall?
I don't think me breaking those did anything.
I'm looking around.
I feel like that room has to have something.
You know, in here.
But maybe it doesn't.
Give you a better angle.
Oh, maybe, maybe that's true.
Let me try one more time just shooting right at it.
Oh.
Yeah.
What's going on?
Oh, no.
Oh, that guy!
The stalker.
You sucker.
Stalker, more like sucker.
Okay, now we shoot it in there and we destroy him.
Or it.
It hit it.
Misses.
It does every...
It misses every time.
That's fine.
Lower, lower.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, now we can do I knew the room would be important for
some reason.
There we go.
Don't fall off the edge now.
Oh, okay.
I'm looking up.
Yeah, we are.
We nailed it.
Okay.
Oh, where?
Ah!
That was close.
Gamers do look up.
Make it to the bottom of the Citadel's main elevator shaft.
In something.
Watch your head.
That was the achievement I just got.
Here it is.
Gamers occasionally look up.
I'm ready
for him.
Oh, you got him.
Good job.
She looks at me like I didn't do shit.
I killed a guy and you killed a guy.
We took them out together.
One tap Alex, they call her.
Why are they also still worried about us?
I do wonder.
Oh.
Why are they hanging around here?
That's what I'm saying.
It looks like they were deliberately trying to blow the
room.
Why?
Oh, maybe because of the baby?
Oh.
Oh, wow.
How can you tell?
Just put a, just put a little cut in it and it'll fizzle
out.
If they're gonna die, they're taking you with them.
It must be.
Oh, I took some hits now, didn't I?
Oh, good.
Or maybe not as many as I thought.
Okay.
What's going on here?
Oh, boy.
Yeah, but what if the baby's on the elevator?
I'm scared of that guy.
Because Voba's weird.
Mmm, Voba.
Oh.
Our elevator.
Gordon, I wish there was something else I could do to help.
What do you mean by that?
What?
Wait.
Why am I going alone?
It really is my elevator.
Wait.
Hello?
Oh, the radiation suit.
That's right.
Detective.
Woo!
The orb.
Hmm, shoot.
I need them to, like, laser, no?
Oh, wait.
What was that?
Something I thought locked on, but I guess not.
Grab a ball.
I don't see- Oh, there they are!
I didn't see them.
Oh, there they are.
I was looking for them.
I was like, are there no balls in there?
Point!
That was...
Oh, I was going to say that was pretty poré, but actually.
That was not poré.
Oh, he gets rid of it because he's a jerk.
Okay, all right.
I should do this one first.
I'm trying to figure out the angle I need to do it at.
Maybe like...
Pew!
Where did...
I don't even know where I went.
Throw the balls at the guys.
Oh, you're so right.
First try?
I think I missed you.
I'm not panicking.
Wait!
Please.
Oh my gosh.
I can't.
He's too tall.
Oh, I got him.
Very nice.
Yeah, that takes care of them then.
Uh...
Alright, so now if I do this, that stays in there.
But I still need to figure out...
Oh, wait.
I can actually...
Oh, I can go in this one.
That's right.
Why am I so...
Okay.
You know what?
Whatever works works.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm
running Alright
And we get over here for...
Oh, the button?
That will let us...
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
And then we go into the big boba.
That's... Oh, yikes, my eyes.
Okay.
I forgot
how the ladders work in this game.
Oh.
Ouch.
My bad.
Sorry.
I'm trying to remember.
Is it space?
Okay, okay.
Wait.
Everything's fine.
I
took mega health damage.
This is the thing.
This part is very puzzling.
Is it now?
I'm getting...
I'm trying to get a look of the area first, I guess, then.
Cool.
Safe.
For now.
It's like also so...
The hearing on it is like very strange.
You know what I mean?
Like the audio is strange on it.
Okay.
We need a ball in here.
Suit juice.
Can I run and make it?
Can I make it?
Okay.
Oh!
I don't quite know what I'm doing.
Um...
What did I do?
Ah!
I hate you!
No, come here.
Oh my god.
Where did you come from?
Okay.
Everything's fine.
I guess I need to go that way.
We'll top off.
Alright, nice.
You guys, I mentioned it literally like two minutes ago.
If the chat freezes, I don't want to keep pausing the game.
I'm just going to get rid of the chat because I don't want
people to keep being like, chat's frozen, chat's frozen.
I can't do anything about it.
I already tried.
Whoa, whoa!
I think I've been sabotaged!
Are they going to come from behind?
Okay.
We're in here.
for a purpose.
Alright.
I'm stuck on their bodies.
Let's move you here.
Move you there.
Let's put a little pile of guys.
This is...
broken.
Oh, it's now on... it's...
Okay, it's shooting to the orb.
Is that all I need to do?
Or...
There's no way, right?
There's, like, more things up there as well.
Do I get higher?
That ladder only goes so high.
Hold on, I'm just looking around.
Is there an elevator of sorts?
You need to do more things.
Yeah, I figured that.
Ooh.
Who is saying hello?
You hear this, like, a lady going, hello.
Hello.
All right, let's go back this way.
Do I?
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, it does!
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Oh, oh, oh.
And cat-like reflexes?
No!
Oh!
Wait, this is a window, right?
Actually, I'm not quite sure what I do with this.
I missed him.
It's Gladys, because it's literally her V8.
No way!
That's crazy.
Maybe I have to...
No, do I have to walk up that?
There's no way.
Use the door as a shield.
Oh, that's so true.
Hmm.
Maybe I just tank it.
Oh, we made it.
Shield who?
I'm a little frightened.
Hello?
We're fine?
Everything's okay.
Everything's...
Hey!
Okay!
We're zapping.
We're zipping and we're zapping.
Alex, you hear me?
I'm doing the thing, I think.
Whoa!
Oh!
What's wrong with you?
Whoa, what's wrong with you?
Wait, why are you...
Why are you...
Whoa, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Calm down, baby, come down.
You want...
You want a fresh...
You want a fresh bobo?
What's up?
What's up with you?
Hold on.
I'm trying to...
That's why you're here.
I'm trying to see what I need to do.
I'm just looking around.
Burp the baby.
I feel like I need to go to the other... I guess maybe...
Let's go see if there's like a door on that side, right?
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Run?
We're running?
Yeah.
I figured there would be something.
Oh!
Holy shit!
Everybody's dead.
Big boba-wine to boba-bo.
Bo-bo?
Oh, what is it, why?
Watch the bodies.
Don't mind the bodies.
Me?
Goombobo.
Oh, I hear them.
Where are they?
This way?
No.
Yes, this way.
Yes?
No, this way.
Oh my gosh, please just come out already.
Okay, it's still, it's getting tamed.
This way?
No way?
I'm going.
I'm going into a trap, I know it.
They're shy.
Here I go.
My health is adequate.
Everything's okay.
Nice.
Good job team.
More?
Anyway, I need to get on there and go to that side it seems.
So, and leave.
Oh,
shoot.
Are you kidding me right now?
I'm gonna miss my stop!
Oh, shoot.
Ow!
Wait, can I put them in the laser?
Yeah, let's put them in the laser.
You are sacrificed to the laser.
Sacrifice.
Oh, my stop!
I missed it!
Vaporize them, yeah.
They're like moths.
To a flame.
Ice.
Oh, hi, Alex.
Can you see me, mom?
Can you see me?
Hi.
I'm doing really dangerous work right now.
All right, here we go.
And...
Oh!
Oh, more guys.
More of them.
They will come eventually.
They're just yapping on that thing.
They're just saying anything and everything.
Oh.
This is a scary area.
A scaria, if you will.
She sees you and looks at you with scourge.
They do be yapping.
What happened?
What are they saying in there?
What could be so important?
Ouch!
I was literally about to say, watch your step.
The sun is a deadly laser.
What a reference.
Wait!
Oh.
I made it.
Somehow.
Oh, we're back in here.
Oh, wait.
Did I just go around or something or how did I get here?
And where do I need to go?
Here we go!
I'm stuck, actually.
Never mind.
Oh, I'm dodging.
Oh, I'm gaming.
Oh, oh, shoot.
I made it!
Got me out of shield?
No way.
She's grazing?
It's fine.
We totally made it, anyway.
So whatever.
I think I need one of these balls.
Wait.
Okay, this should be the last one, right?
This should be all calm and cool and collected.
Wait, what happened?
All calm and cool and collected?
I have to go in there.
Oh my god.
That's so loud.
What's going on in here?
I'm not an electrician.
I actually don't know how to fix it.
Does it need a ball each?
Wait, how do I get out?
I need three balls.
But where do I get them from?
Unless?
Wait.
Look up.
Oh, they're here!
Okay, thank you.
One ball for you?
And one...
Wrong button.
One...
One ball for you.
Oh, you were early.
Wait, um...
Oh!
Wait, uh, how did the fire get put out?
Hello?
Uh, there we go.
Easy peasy.
Here we go.
Yeah, what do you mean?
I figured it out!
No problem!
Oh, do I need to do it again?
That's right.
There we go.
Finish the process.
I like the puzzles in this.
No!
Contained the Citadel Core.
I got an achievement.
But, okay, that means we should be safe, though, right?
Because, um, I have no more health.
Or no more, you know.
I think this might be a bad idea.
explode to get rid of the the guys yeah they nerfed my gun
Alex hello Gordon yep the containment systems back in place
it won't last forever but at least we've bought a little
time while you were in there I did some poking around in the
control data oh yeah they were trying to start a chain
reaction all right but destroying the Citadel is just a side
effect since we took out they have to send a transmission
packet back to wherever they came from i see i can't tell
what the packet contains but it's important enough that
they're willing to sacrifice the whole citadel to send it
off we need to get it back to my dad and dr cliner at the
outpost right away did we prove ourselves guys whatever it
is i have a feeling it's bad news for all of us bad news
bears even there's something else what do you mean there's
something else it's judith take a look judith she's the lady
that betrayed us right i'm fairly sure i've pinned down the
location of the project it's hard to say how much of it
might have survived intact or whether there's anything
remaining that could compromise our work if it were
discovered by the combine we'll need to take a close look at
it of course but i think betrayed me yes i mean fake
betrayed me if the site is where we think it is then it
should be no more difficult i'm gonna cut this short we may
have been spotted uh-oh where the hell is
Whoa!
Uh-oh.
I think he's doing a great job.
Thanks, Jimmy!
He'll know what to do with you.
Yes.
Okay.
Now let's get the hell out of here.
Oh.
Did we get company?
It's this way.
Okay.
We're running.
Nice.
Most dangerous flash drive.
Okay, you told me to run.
Something tells me they don't want us bringing their mail.
Oh, shoot!
This will take us to a train platform.
If we can hitch a ride, it should take us straight out of
the city.
Oh, nice!
And we're certain it's working.
Yeah, sadly.
It was.
I'm looking up just in case.
Just in case.
Alright.
Cool.
All aboard the train!
We're not gonna get ambushed, right?
Because I don't have anything to defend.
Help us.
Woo!
Then let's skedaddle?
Oh, I got you.
I've handled these before.
Here we go.
Oh.
Now they're, they're friends.
Oh, they're so cute.
Yeah.
Here he comes.
What do I do?
What do you want me to do?
Yeah!
Spicy soccer!
Oh, oh my god!
I need you to protect me.
Coast is clear.
like ma'am I have no gun I have no nothing okay oh thank
goodness
uh Alex oh my gosh why did it become red you know all things
considered we're not doing oh no What?
It's a stalker car.
What does that mean?
Oh my god!
Damn, the combine!
This is what happens to you if you resist!
The least sexy model, they just have no feet.
Well, they're just in the wrong place at the wrong time.
Well, they're...
Yeah, just, just, uh...
Oh yeah, there was that whole factory, right?
That made the stalkers?
Her dad almost became one!
That was it, right?
I'm pretty sure.
We should be well out of the city before it's too late.
Yeah, I remember, I remember the prison.
Yes, yes.
It is freaky.
Let's hope the worst is over.
I mean, a train is still a train.
It could be a stalker train.
You're welcome.
I ask for nothing in return.
What's that?
Unless.
Oh my god.
What?
Use your words.
Brace yourself.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
What if I only had two HP left?
Ew, don't talk to me.
Help?
Or are you okay?
I'm coming.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
What do I do?
Try pulling.
No, the door said push.
Oh my god, these guys are nasty.
Are you okay?
This thing.
Ugh, shut.
Oh.
It's okay.
Actually, I feel the same exact way.
Um, let's go this way.
Shhh, it's- yeah, let's get away from them.
They're nasty.
Ma'am!
Hold up a sec.
What?
I gotta catch my breath.
Yeah, I'm blaming you.
That guy's breath was nasty!
Okay.
Well, this might not be as easy as I thought.
We're in the same boat as the other evacuees now.
On foot to a train station.
Let's head for the surface.
Well, we have guns and things.
And brains.
And brawn.
Maybe.
She actually got traumatized there.
I would be too.
That guy was so...
Like, that guy was on her.
You know?
Oh.
Careful.
I hear turrets.
Yeah, I heard that too.
Cool as a cucumber.
But there's also all head...
Oh.
It's right there.
Oh, is it focused on the rat?
Oh!
There was a head crab behind me!
Did you save my life?
I thought it was a...
I thought it was a rat.
I didn't think it was a head crab.
Soup.
Okay, there's another turret.
How do we get past these?
Oh my god.
Okay, it's like taking them out, though.
Or she is?
She is taking them out.
I'm doing my part.
Watch out for the...
Is there any weapon for me to use?
Nope.
All you girl, all you.
Good job.
Are these guys going to get me?
Hold on.
I don't remember what they do.
I guess.
It's locked on me.
Oh, that's the kid.
That's what it is.
Oh, okay.
Scared for a second.
I'm stuck on a rock.
Oh.
It's going to...
But then these guys...
Oh.
Watch out for that.
Shoot him!
And...
We're fine.
Hopper mines.
Scary.
Is this guy gonna get up?
Yeah, and then he'll get got by the mine.
Don't worry about him.
Don't...
Oh, she's...
Yeah!
Burn him!
I feel so defensive.
I feel so defenseless.
Like, what do I...
Oh!
What was that?
Hmm.
Can you throw anything?
I could throw, like, this truck?
Or is there something I was locking?
This box?
I could throw boxes.
Not much.
okay this is a little scary alex i want you to go first me
all right if you insist i can't see a thing yeah that's why
i have a flashlight yeah me too we need to get through that
door uh oh what's that yep i've heard stories about you and
air ducts what does that mean says whenever he locked
himself out of his office you and Barney used to compete to
see who would get in the fastest without using a key does
the sorry does the darkness make you mute what happened why
is the music scary all of a sudden you're coming in right
nope absolutely not
What is this again?
Is that health?
I don't want to go down there.
What's that?
Whoa!
Oh, well, uh, I lost it.
Sorry, buddy.
It was health.
Reverse escort mission.
Does that mean you're getting princess carried?
Yeah.
I guess I could have held on to it, so I could, uh, you
know.
Did I kill him?
I'm getting princes carried?
Whoop!
Where's...
Yeah!
Stinking head crab.
These guys look...
Dead?
That guy is half a body?
You're crawling.
Probably dead.
You give me that?
I have to let it recharge my power.
He is half alive.
Scary!
You said the thing!
That's...
How can I get that?
Wait, okay, let's just...
Oh.
Oh, awesome.
I don't have a gun.
Why is it teasing me?
Oh, I'm looking around.
Look up the grit.
What grit?
Oh, where I came from?
Wait, where did I come from?
here nothing is there anything else hold on it's so narrow
it's so hard to see
up and over the fence like here wait no i saw it because i
see oh wait i see this um but it doesn't let me pull it down
um gun on the shelf there is what are you talking about
there maybe But I can't get in there.
Play like the Valve playtesters.
I need yellow...
I forgot that I had my...
Oh, but now now I can...
Hold on now though.
I can...
What's it called?
Blast open the door.
Oh, I didn't really need that.
I was just trying to grab everything.
That's fine though.
No, please.
There we go.
Oh.
Nice job.
Thanks.
Hey, and you found a gun.
I found a gun!
Wait, I want this.
I want this though.
Wait, now I have to do stuff?
Ugh.
No, I'm just kidding.
Now I have to do stuff!
Okay, now I have to remember where all the keybinds are,
though.
That's the kind of...
That's the part that gets a little...
Icky.
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
Put
your light on that zombie.
Oh.
So whatever one I highlight, she goes after.
Thank you.
Okay, it makes sense.
Oh, there was fire.
Right there.
We missed it.
I'm going to run out of electricity, though, so...
That guy's really dead.
For real?
What the heck is that?
Fire.
Okay, yeah.
Keep your light on that.
This one?
No, no, this one.
Now this one.
Some kind of space bug.
Wait, I actually need to, uh...
Wait, that's health.
I actually need to let it recharge.
Ah, she forgot.
Keep your light on that zombie.
Oh, come on.
I was recharging.
Good job, Alex.
We'll just keep going.
Uh.
This way?
Follow their...
The Combine's defense field must have collapsed.
Oh!
Wait!
Oh, yeah!
That's what these guys are!
I remember!
Wait!
My bug friends!
Good job.
Oh.
And stay down!
I could control them if I had the sack.
I think this guy's good.
I have no ammo on him, though.
Oh, this guy is definitely not.
Oh, looks like we found a troop train.
Why don't you speak?
Use your words, Alex.
What the hell is that?
A headcraft?
Combine zombie.
What's...
That's like a... a... a...
Zombine.
Right?
Still loving your content.
Thank you, James!
Oh him?
Crap!
Look out!
It's got a grenade!
Ah!
I can't move!
We're fine.
Also, can I go in here?
No, dang.
I thought I found a secret tunnel.
Wait, was there anything over here?
Uh, no.
Cool.
Just make it short.
Alright.
Classic Alex.
Uh, well that was easy.
Very nice.
Good job, team.
Do we power this?
Oh!
I didn't realize there was a door here.
Dang.
What?
Quit your whining.
All I hear is...
All day, all night.
I want it.
What is that guy?
Holy cow!
Oh, shoot!
Ouch, for me too.
Oh, they're getting eaten?
Holy cow.
She's kind of... Oh, shoot.
Oh, dang it.
I died.
Oops, my bad.
Okay.
Oh, there's, like, a horde now.
Okay, good to know.
Wait, am I going the right way?
No, I'm not going the right way.
Um, well, that was a lot.
Okay.
I was trying to run away from him, but I kept getting
stopped on something.
All right, let's, uh...
Hmm.
I wonder if this would be...
Better if I can just kind of blow them up, like, with that,
you know?
Okay.
Oh, you cannot.
Oh, shoot.
This is really bad timing.
Uh, Alex?
Ah!
We're fine.
Music kind of bumping, though.
Yeah.
Alright, let's just, uh, go, I guess.
I'm scared, but I will be brave.
I thought
it was my flare.
I'm trying to change weapons, but it won't let me.
Wait, why can't I change a weapon?
I'm pressing four.
Oh, because I only have two.
No.
My thing got wasted.
That's okay.
If I have to do it again, it's fine.
I'm...
Oh.
Keep that vertical in your head.
Yeah, screw that gun.
No, definitely four was the shotgun, but I don't have it
anymore, unfortunately.
Oh, I need health like bad bad though.
Ah!
Yeah, my shotgun's out of ammo, so I was trying to get to
it, but I didn't realize.
Please die.
Looks
like we need to find you a med kit.
Oh, thank goodness!
Well, we take these.
I wish I had my crowbar.
Wait.
As a relatively new viewer, I thought you'd find it funny to
know I discovered you and Lyme's through Vinny.
Wait, through Vinny?
I need.
How?
How through Vinny?
Thank you, though.
No crowbar, I miss you.
I also miss not having to use my... Wait.
How the hell do I use this thing, man?
It's so annoying.
There we go.
Okay, actually, it kind of...
Maybe I don't like it.
Oh, I actually don't know where it went either.
I think I He threw it into the abyss.
Alex, I'm lost.
I think, oh, we need to activate this.
So was there a thing on the...
Let's look for a thing on the wall to open it.
Danger, uh, not high voltage.
Oh, here it is.
Sorry.
How was...
How was slow?
He reacted to talking about his diaper chief bit.
I talked about meeting you at MGS event.
Yeah!
There was a, um...
There was a pop-up in New York City.
And I happened to meet him there.
Oh, my flashlight.
Let's let it read.
George, a bit.
Take your mask.
I'm afraid of there being, what's it called, guys again.
Maybe it's okay.
You good?
What was that?
That's weak?
Oh, it's this one.
It's the nasty one.
I hate these things.
Me too!
Everything is like coming back to me slowly but surely.
You know what I mean?
Okay, I still only have my pistol.
Okay, I think I hear another one.
Do I?
Yes.
Ouch, ow, ow, ow.
Oh, shit.
Alex, I need your help.
I think there was one more, no?
There was one over here?
I didn't kill it.
It ran away?
Or something?
Ah!
Did I actually get down to 1 HP?
No way, that's crazy.
Holy cow.
I think there's nothing else over here, though.
Let's go.
Oh.
Sudden ambiance.
No, we have to go back in the hole.
No.
Ah!
I got you.
Oh.
I'm...
I can blow it, I can blast it!
It's dead, it's dead!
I can blast it?
Are these, is this just never ending?
Do I need to figure out what to do here?
Yeah, we're all out.
Let's see, what does this do?
She's got it.
Oh!
I got it.
Is it done?
Did I do it?
Just block the hole.
Okay, can I get back to what I was doing now?
Oh my god.
wait I didn't think that would actually work but I guess it
did did that actually work
oh my god it's like ridiculous sounding look at that guy
crawling away over there it sucks because head crabs are
like kind of cute you know oh sure I blocked the hole!
Well, she said, like, cut off their supply, so, um...
I just put a lid on it.
Yeah, take that guy.
Okay.
In here?
Oh my god, are we kidding me right now!
Alex, what are we supposed to do here?
Okay, but what about the other 15 of them?
Alright, you get that guy.
There is an attempt.
Oh, nice!
Blew that guy up.
Wait, can I also blow up more guys?
Oh.
It did nothing.
They can eat explosives, that's true.
Maybe we have them eat...
Oh, stop shooting!
them?
That's right.
I didn't see any explosives though, did you guys?
I think we could probably get through here.
Oh wait, also, yeah, here you go.
I forgot.
I just remembered.
Here you go.
Eat up, eat up.
Is that guy dead?
Is this the one I shot?
Yeah.
Okay, that guy's not dead.
Eat up, eat up, oh, oops.
Ow!
Eat up, eat up.
We just gotta get through.
Uh-oh.
Uh, I'm screwed.
Oh, I'm screwed.
Ah!
Oh.
We did it?
If it were It works.
It works.
Oh, don't worry about it.
We got a hole in the wall now.
But this says exit.
Wait, but what about the hole in the wall?
That was so nasty.
OP NPC.
Oh, oh.
There's some stuff in here.
I'll grab it.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for you.
Wait, what's that?
Oh, nice.
Oh, cool.
Okay.
Yeah.
Nice.
I can't believe the door actually worked, though.
That's the most surprising bit.
You know?
Now, once again, I'm in the front.
And that concerns me.
P5.
Alex?
There we are.
Alex has a fear of the dark.
Oh, does she?
Me too though.
Okay.
Oh.
It is pretty spooky in here.
That's why I ran?
Let those guys handle it?
Oh, I guess I...
I can get a better shot if you knock them over, Jordan.
Knock them over.
I can also do that.
She has plot armor.
I know, it's great.
I love that.
I don't have to worry about...
Where was he looking?
Did you see that?
I don't have to worry.
Oh, I have to...
They're going to keep coming out of this, aren't they?
Maybe?
Probably?
Did he block his own hole?
No, is this their hole?
Oh, they have many holes.
They have multiple holes.
I don't think I can block this.
one maybe I can I
but yeah I love that I don't have to worry about her like
needing HP or anything or seemingly at least you know
oh I can't find another car or so oh my gosh there's so many
of these guys does that I don't think they Hold on, I'm
going up here.
Oh, maybe I can get this car.
Please, uh...
Okay, good.
Don't die on me!
Don't look at the delayed cars out.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, okay, we're fine.
Maybe I do need another one for...
Or rather...
Oh yeah, they're definitely coming through this one.
Okay, um, I need one more car.
One more...
There it is.
Just give me a second, Alex.
You can handle it.
I believe in you.
Oh.
I kind of didn't need that, huh?
Oh, thank you.
Hold on, I'm trying to figure out how to get in there.
You just handle these guys.
Can I get in through here?
I don't think so, no.
I think I gotta, like, go...
Oh, my God.
Alex, I really need you to cover me.
Okay, here I go.
I'm running.
Alright, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Awesome.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Never mind.
I gotta do it again.
Okay, yeah, I'm going.
I'm running.
Oh, I have no...
Okay.
We're fine.
Don't worry about it!
Wait, where'd the car...
Oh, there's the car.
Where'd the car go?
Oh.
Alright, do your best, Alex!
Where's she keeping you?
all that ammo.
She does reload.
But, um, yeah, good question.
Alright, we're gonna have a nice peaceful bug-free time
soon.
Oh, ow.
Nice.
Oh, my gosh.
Are there stragglers?
It's so loud.
It's so...
You would think they would be able to handle that.
Like, just a car?
I think it would break eventually?
But I guess not!
Okay.
Where is she, anyway?
Alex!
Where's she go?
She's not right behind me, where is she, actually?
Cars are heavy.
lift a car.
You know what?
You're so right.
I don't think I could lift a car either.
What was I thinking?
You wouldn't lift a car.
I have tried.
Oh, you can hear yourself think.
With all this ruckus?
I'm glad one of us can.
Oh, I can hear myself think amongst the cartoon crash sound
effects.
Bitcoin.
Oh, yeah, I have to go along here now.
Oh, I see the other wheel that I need to turn.
The physics engine makes them look easy to move, to be fair.
That's true.
That's very true.
No!
Slowly but surely.
I hope nobody attacks me!
While I turn this wheel!
Okay, let's go.
Nice.
Oh.
I think I just sit.
I hear a...
I hear crying.
I hear a sad guy.
Oh, he's down there.
What is in here?
Oh, no.
What's down here?
Oh, oh, no.
I need to get him.
Because I can't.
Oh, good job.
Sorry.
Oh, I need to get it.
Okay, this is awkward.
Okay, yeah, you go down there.
Disturb the witch.
Okay, now I go in there.
Okay, Alex, Alex, please.
Alex, Alex.
All right, now you move, and I go up.
Dancing in front of me.
Ready?
All right, let's go in here.
What the...
You're lucky you've got that hazard suit.
This water's nasty.
You got room for two in there?
You went in my...
You went...
Ah!
You went in my suit?
Oh!
He's angry.
You went in my suit?
Alex, it's a little forward now, don't you think?
Wait, oh.
Oh, like, ah, my shot...
Wait, so I have shotgun again.
Oh, okay!
I didn't realize.
Awesome.
I blow that up preemptively it will kill them probably not
right is that allowed is this why it was called a date I
shot too early
ouch oh I'm on my grab gun yeah can you help me I'm
scratching my nose actually I have an itch I'm
gonna go back and I'm gonna get more shotgun oh I'll be
right back.
Yeah, cover me.
Cover me.
Oh, where is this guy coming from?
Oh, they're coming from another door.
Okay.
Is there anything in here?
Oh!
Look at that!
It pays to explore.
Alright, I don't like this area.
Like, the lighting messes with my eyes, you know.
It's not a box of Chinese food.
Not even the sewers are safe.
Is that guy dead?
You think?
Ooh.
It's really loud in here.
I really want to be out of these dark areas.
Please let there be a way to the surface.
For real!
Like, I'm actually...
I'm so sick of it.
My flashlight...
Hi!
Holy white noise.
I know, right?
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, nothing else in here.
Let's go.
Anything else?
Oh, no.
This looks enjoyable.
Okay.
I don't believe it.
An actual elevator.
Here we go.
This part is the worst.
It does not look good, I'm gonna be honest.
It looks quite bad.
Oh.
You've got to be kidding.
Yeah, hold off arena.
That's how I'm thinking, too.
Oh,
a power supply.
Somewhere.
Oh, okay.
Uh.
Okay.
Let's try this way, then.
Oh, gosh.
It looks so scary.
Nothing.
Alright.
I wasted that.
I thought it was coming.
Let's check out where that sparking wire leads.
Oh, good plan.
I was just looking around aimlessly, to be honest.
Sparking wire leads in where I just went.
Above.
Wow, there's a lot of stuff in here.
Oh, no.
Flares can help.
Can they now?
There's a lot going on here.
Or, like, rather, this room is very big for it to be, like,
a, uh, a, um, hold off the, you know.
Is that, is that the wire?
Yeah, the wire goes in here.
Oh, you cannot win this on guns.
Oh.
I gotta talk to Dr. Kleiner about getting a new battery for
that flashlight.
I agree.
Well, I was gonna say, to hold off the horde, this seems
like a...
A really large room is all I was trying to say before.
Yes.
Oops.
Where did you come from?
Okay.
Well, we cleared up those stragglers, I guess.
Gather the explosives at the elevator.
You know what?
That's a good plan.
That's what I was thinking of doing, but I didn't know if I
needed...
Rather...
Okay.
I didn't know what kind of...
What kind of was gonna happen, you know what I mean?
So...
If I know that I need to gather these here, I will do so.
Oh.
Don't know.
Don't jigs me.
You guys.
Please.
I wait.
Shine your light on that thing.
Where did he come from?
I literally was over there and there was nothing there.
Am I crazy?
Wait, where the heck did he come from?
Oh my god.
Alex, please have the best...
Stop shooting!
Okay, we're fine.
Random spawns.
Oh, did they do that?
Okay.
I didn't know if they did that in this part.
Maybe.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Gather these, and then I'm gonna try for it.
Because I don't know what to expect yet.
So, um...
Actually, first, we're gonna let my power...
oh my god oh my god
I was gonna let it
I was gonna let it recharge
I give up I give up we're just gonna open the door now oh my
god I cannot believe he threw that and it landed upright
that's kind of insane okay alright let's go
oh awkward That
was awkward.
All right.
Uh, generator thing.
Hey, I hear the elevator.
It's moving again.
Oh, and here comes trouble.
Oh!
Oh, sorry.
Oh, maybe I shouldn't waste some.
Uh.
Wait, where did my thing go?
Okay.
Ow, she says.
How long will this take?
Hopefully, that's too long.
It's okay, we have light because of them.
I honestly, it's fine.
But I...
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
Ah!
It's okay.
I can always restart it.
That's a great question.
I would also care to know.
What if I hid here?
I shot it though.
Alex has died!
She can die.
She can die!
She's moving again.
No way.
I learned.
Today I learned.
Oh,
I thought she said murder.
I am.
Murder!
Heading the Duke University appointment with my care team.
Oh, good luck!
Oh,
he can't.
I
keep hitting F and G simultaneously oh my god it's this guy
it's these guys they suck oh
sorry oh
my god
oh my god oh my god oh my
god Okay, first try.
Survive long enough to get on the parking garage elevator.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I hope it's still light out.
Apparently, some people said it's easier than it.
Oh, they nerfed it, did they?
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh.
Thank God.
It's still day.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe this.
I'll handle it.
Excuse me.
Can you let us out of here?
Radica?
They can't hear us, I guess.
We're locked.
Hold on, I gotta go.
Actually, can you see any way to get this open?
Uh, yeah.
Uh, yes.
Um, give me like two seconds.
Actually, I have to go get some more water, you guys.
I have to drink extra water because it's so dusty in my
cafe.
I'm moving lots of stuff and the dust gets in my throat.
So I'll be right back.
I'll be right back.
I
am back.
I am back.
Welcome back, thank you!
One second!
And...
Let's do this.
I sure hope there's nothing in here that's gonna try and
kill me.
Some way!
Crank that soldier boy.
that wall.
Um, what if I blasted it?
Hmm.
Looks like there used to be a crank that fit in here.
I wonder if it's still around here somewhere.
It would have to be in here.
I didn't see it though.
I was looking to see if there was something that showed.
Maybe I just...
Wait, is it in the briefcase?
I wonder if it's still around someplace.
Let's check this.
It's probably very important.
Look in there.
Okay, anyway.
Oh, wait.
What if I...
No, I can't take that one, you guys.
It has an important duty to do.
Like a valve?
Halfway through episode one!
Halfway through?
Hope you're enjoying yourself through all the screams.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I thought people said this took like three hours.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
What the hell?
That's it.
See if the crank still works.
Well, we might be in for a while then.
Great.
Okay.
Let's get to the train yard before the Citadel blows.
I'm in streaming for almost three.
What?
Oh, there they are.
Oh my gosh.
Ew!
Wait, please, no!
We place our firmest hope in the human spirit.
I've never been happier to see Dr. Kleiner.
For real.
Ooh.
Oh, even a guy here.
Alright, you ready?
I think this is the way we go.
Let me check the other side just in case.
that we retain our humanity only this will allow us to hold
together as we must for their inevitable return and what is
certain to be unimaginable retaliation and oh yes if you
missed any part of this message it will loop repeatedly
until there is no point in looping it any longer I apologize
for any inadvertent errors or omissions as you imagine we
have had scarcely time to record let alone rehearse what's
that Eli oh right right this has been dr. Isaac Kleiner
formerly of black Mesa now simply a citizen like all of you
of earth you let me just add you were you were a citizen
before struggle out of the shadow of our malefactors welcome
back to the light oh thank you I was stuck in underground
for so long oh my god what a nerd anything over here Doesn't
look like it.
Alright.
Let's go back.
Careful, Lamar.
These lamps are quite hot.
He's doing his best, yeah.
Probably us.
Oh my gosh.
I had my dang gun out.
Probably us.
Why do they still care?
Uh-oh.
You loud?
She's just standing there?
I was hoping we'd get a bit farther before they noticed us
again.
I wish I had my old thing again.
Oh, we're getting our guns back and stuff.
The one that allows me to shoot people with my gravity gun.
I miss that.
I miss being able to do that.
It's so fun.
I want to keep my pistol.
Okay.
Okay, cool.
Okay, we just go.
Whoa!
More of them.
Are you friend?
Join my team.
Join me.
Oh,
we gotta block their nest again.
I can get a better shot if you knock them over, Gordon.
Oh, shoot.
That should be one.
Oh, never mind.
Hopefully.
My foolproofs methodology?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, there was a car right here.
My bad.
Oh, my God.
No, no, no, no, no.
Wait.
Hold on.
Let me take care of the bugs.
I can't do one thing at a time.
Okay, we got him.
Oh, it's a man versus bug.
Did they kill him in the air?
Cover me while I reload.
I got you.
He's getting got by bug.
Splat.
Yeah, you like splatted in the air.
I think they shot him down, but it was just kind of funny.
Grab that.
Oh, there must be more, though.
Take this one.
Okay.
That should be good.
You're welcome.
Everybody here?
Wait, where's our friend?
You're coming with, right?
Come on.
Where's going?
What is she doing?
What are you doing?
Where are you going?
I saved your ass.
Come on.
What the heck?
Yeah,
she was running away from me.
Do I smell or something?
Like, I feel like everybody is always, you know?
Alright, well, let's go in, I guess.
Watch out!
Oh.
Do that?
I guess I could have done that to kill that guy, huh?
Well, there might be more guys dying.
Ooh, it's toasty in here.
It's toasty in here now.
I'll cover the street.
Figure what out?
What am I figuring out?
That sounds kind of gassy.
Do they want me?
Oh.
Oh, come on.
Okay.
Okay, I gotta put something else down here.
They hint with...
Wait, maybe this rock.
The heavy rock.
Which feels like it's not heavy at all.
We'll do...
We'll do this too.
Yeah?
Alright, that better be it.
Are we kidding right now?
Heavy milk crate, yeah?
And more...
No, oh, no, no.
I need them inside the milk crate.
I wish I could, like, turn it, you know?
Yeah, Alex, if you could just stand here...
I guess that my suit is really...
Oh, no, suit.
wait oh I thought that was I thought it was a safe but I was
like that thing's going to be really heavy hmm me surely now
oh no
the chairs I'll put anything
how much does Gordon way in his suit can I knock over like
one of these like how just have it kind of right there he
weighs at least one rock and two chairs wait what about that
ah come on all the heavy stuff I can't pick up
Blame the suit.
Ow!
I was so close!
What if, though?
What if I...
Oh, oops.
What if I stack the chairs underneath?
Or, like, stack the stuff underneath instead.
Hey, guys.
Don't give hints unless I ask for it.
What the heck?
I see you guys literally saying exactly what I just said.
I see you.
You guys are literally saying exactly what I just said, but
you're just...
Let me figure it out, okay?
Oh my gosh.
What the heck?
You guys are saying no help.
You need to say it to the other chatters.
Not to me.
I don't think there was anything else that I could pick up,
though.
So we gotta work.
We gotta make do with this...
Uh...
I wish I could bring a car in.
Oh, I don't even think this is gonna...
I'm like stacking it so haphazardly.
I don't think this is gonna work at all the way I have it
done.
I don't think this is gonna...
Mito's extra cute today.
No elp needed.
How am I extra cute?
I
wonder how far down it goes.
Let's stack it like up here.
Why?
No, please.
Alright, Rock, stop it.
No, Rock, stop it from rolling!
Rock, I need you!
No!
You'll get it, don't worry.
Yeah, wait, actually, wait, I have a better idea.
Watch this.
Like here.
I have a better idea.
Maybe like that.
Yippee!
Oh.
Oh, thank goodness.
Finally, this gas hissing was so annoying.
She did it!
You know, most gamers quit at that moment.
Most gamers say...
Oh, hello.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Let's head upstairs.
Where's the stairs?
Oh, here.
Most gamers give up at that point.
They say this is way too tough for me.
We can at least get...
Oh, I was going to do it for you.
Dang it.
Hey!
Did you just throw a bottle at me?
Oh shoot.
Get the roller.
No, get the roller.
Oh my god!
Stop!
You're right shooting.
He's so mean.
Helicopter?
I could do the same thing.
Oh.
Picking up everything.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, sniper.
Wait.
Is that what I think it was?
Oh, I thought it was the little things that...
Oh, I remember how to get rid of those.
You have to, like, have the bomb and throw it back to them.
I remember.
Hold on, I'm making sure I didn't miss anything.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Let's crouch.
Um, wait, I'm gonna bring it to you!
Free programming!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you think then I can throw it at them?
Look out, boss.
It's the enemy sniper.
It's one of my favorite lines.
Yeah, throw it at the sniper.
That's what I'm thinking.
don't get upset don't get upset she's mad he's growling at
him okay
oh it's going out it's going it's going down in there though
wait it did something
Alex oh it's going at him Wait, there's another one.
Oh, come here, come here, come here.
Yeah, yeah, there you go, there you go.
Oh,
it's on the ground.
Dang it, I missed him.
Come back, come back.
There's two of them.
Oh wait, they're both down there.
Well, he's distracted, that's okay.
Anyway.
They came back.
They came back to me!
I was short.
Let's try again.
I know.
Ha!
Oh, shoot.
I'm sorry.
Ah!
Oh, I think I was hot.
Ouch.
Okay, wait.
I'm going to reload.
Wait, what is reload?
F8?
Wait, guys, I know how to quick save, but I don't know how
to quick load.
I mean, quick load.
Wait.
F9?
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
All right, let's try again.
Wait, there's the other one down here, Nolo.
No, no, no, no, no.
Where are you going?
Oh, shoot.
Come here.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Ouch!
Okay.
Oh yeah, I'm not gonna try from here anymore.
I think it's a little silly to keep going like this.
Gordon, hold up a second.
We can't get through here while that sniper's covering the
street.
I know!
Don't get blown up, don't get blown up.
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh my god!
Here, here, there you go, there you go.
ouch!
Stop!
Nice try though.
There was an attempt, for sure.
Oh.
He won't stop shooting down here.
That's why it's even tougher, I think.
We're pinned down.
We need some way to take out those- I know, I know, I know.
I think the first try I had was so good because Ouch, ouch,
ouch.
Stop!
Stop hitting it out of my hand!
It was so good before because I at least made it in the
building, but I don't know why this sniper didn't get got.
Ah!
Yeah, like...
Wait!
I think maybe it was too low before.
Hey, stop it!
He bounces it back!
You asshole.
Uh oh, ouch, ouch.
I like how the person said you have so much health, but you
don't realize that his sniper takes so much health too.
His sniper does crazy damage.
That's why I kept reloading.
I can't go out there while that sniper's covering me.
Alex!
Shut up!
I'm dealing with the problem!
Okay, come here, come here.
No, come here!
Please!
Please, please, please, please go in the hole.
Please, please come back home actually now.
If I die, I don't care anymore.
I'll just reload.
Do you have any grenades?
No.
I do not.
But I'll run to the other side and see.
Maybe there's some grenades in here.
There's not!
I don't want to quick load.
My things aren't coming back for some reason.
Where are they?
Like, I can't even try to grab them.
Thanks for the helpful observation.
Oh, they're gonna drop one, I think.
Whoa!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Would you survive this?
Rinto?
I'm so glad I'm already dead.
I don't have to think about it.
Ouch.
Ouch, oh my god, please.
Okay.
Lower.
It sucks as I can't do anything, you know, until...
Until I get him back.
Let's try getting closer.
Oh, my guy is there.
Oh, shit!
Shit, shit, shit, shit!
I tried.
It's so frustrating.
Gordon, hold on a second.
We can't get through here while that sniper's covering the
street.
Oh!
The girls are fighting.
Wait, can you come here?
No, stop.
Girls, girls!
Girls!
Don't, don't, don't touch him!
Oh, you're going.
after the bug.
Okay.
I can't run.
Ouch.
I can't run while I'm holding it.
I'm gonna die.
Please do something about it.
Thank you.
Oh, they're fighting the other one.
The new one.
I think there's a new one.
Okay, I get it.
I can't do much either.
I'm struggling hardcore.
Ouch!
It's just absolute chaos right now.
No, please come here.
Wait!
Did I get him?
It looks like it goes in, but then it doesn't at the same-
Oh, I think I got him!
I got the sniper!
No, no, come, come, come, come, come.
Stop it!
Uh-oh.
That's...
How we could have used him?
Oh, leak, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, we could have used that.
Good job, Alex.
My God.
Nice toss, Gordon.
That sniper almost took my head off.
Shut up.
Shut up right now.
There was a grenade down here.
Let me climb up and take a look at what we're walking into.
You do that.
I'm looking around.
What do you mean, uh-oh.
Oh, it's fortified.
Wait.
I'll cover you from up here till you reach the far end.
When the coast is clear, I'll catch up.
Okay, looks like I can get that ladder down to you.
Let me shoot at the latch.
Huh?
I might be a little rusty with this rifle.
Oh!
I'm not.
Whoa!
That was a cooler way of doing it, though.
Yeah, you're so right.
So, you're gonna cover me, right?
You're gonna be just as good as that guy, right?
Wait, what do you have me doing here?
Oh, I'm on grenades.
You know what?
Screw it.
Ah!
I wish I could, um, here, I'll go to this.
What am I doing down here?
What do you have me doing?
Oh.
Oh, nasty, nasty.
Quiet humming.mp3.
He's dead.
this is this is so half-life isn't it this is the half-life
we all know and love is that you or who that who's which
sniper is this oh okay she's gonna get yeah nice shot find
the computer room okay thank you i was too You know.
To everything going on for me to listen to her.
She's gonna cover me?
Yeah?
Help Alex snipe 30 enemies in episode 1.
Oh shit, Broadway.
Oh, Broadway.
Ah!
Oops, okay.
Where are we?
Oh, we're up here.
Let's not have it on the grenades.
Let's...
Oh.
Submachine gun?
Suddenly life is beautiful, starts playing.
Did that kill them?
That's so funny.
If it did.
Wait, I think it did.
No way!
I feel like I was on the right track though.
I'll let her get him.
Okay, get him.
What were you doing?
Alex, come on, girl.
Sorry,
I'm just gonna...
I gotta keep saving when I can.
I think I want my shotgun after all.
Alright, here they come!
You got this?
Nice!
Alright, next guy?
He's gonna stand up and you're gonna take him.
Oh, so close.
Wait, hold on.
I'll help you.
I'll help you out!
There you go!
It's an open window concept!
It's an open window concept.
Where's everybody else?
They all came...
coming for me before, right?
I'll save, I guess.
Here they come.
Alright, all you.
Holy shit.
Okay, we got him.
I don't know.
My flashlight's still alive.
Hold on.
Oh, I don't...
I do not have...
Oh, I don't have any more ammo.
Any more shotgun ammo.
This looks like a good place to lure things to.
Yeah!
I'm into Half-Life on my birthday.
Adios!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Alright.
Maybe I'll go back to my pistol.
I feel so much better with it.
Can I save?
Alright.
There's gotta be someone behind there.
You know?
Computer room.
Still searching for a computer room.
Oh, shoot.
Oh shit, look
at this.
Oh my god.
Well, I made it into the hole, but there were many people
shooting me.
Oh.
I forgot how tough episode 1 was with no crowbar.
Are you able to get one at any point?
Okay, I think she took them out maybe.
Oh, she is at least.
Computer room.
Why couldn't she join me down here?
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
My bad.
Yeah, if there's something that's, like, spoilery, I'll look
away from chat, obviously, but...
Okay, now, hmm.
She's giving you sniper cover.
Yeah, she's doing a really great job with that.
Okay, uh...
car.
This is what we'll do.
Oh, hello.
Ouch!
Who?
From where?
Oh my god.
Over there.
Wait.
Bad guy?
Friend?
Foe.
Foe, foe, foe, foe, foe, foe, foe, foe.
Okay.
I think I gotta take that guy out first.
That guy will actually kill me.
She's like trying to get him.
I wonder if I can grab gun that part.
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, there we go.
How are you still alive?
Wait, please help.
Alex, actually, help.
I need you to actually shoot those things.
Okay, I need to...
Shit!
Help!
Okay, we got him.
I think.
Yes?
Oh.
Help Alex- Oh, I got the achievement again.
Help Alex snipe 30 enemies.
Alright.
Help.
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck?
Oh, they're coming through now.
Okay.
They open up the door.
Do I have to wait for them to do that?
I shouldn't have to, I don't think.
I wish I could control the bugs again.
So good, you got it to us.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I just got another achievement.
Is it this door?
It must be.
Nope.
I'm a liar.
Oh shoot please.
Oh I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
Oh.
Don't do that!
You're gonna unleash them!
Maybe I do go through the door.
Oh, never mind.
I must go through the door then.
I'm in!
My storage are free!
Uh...
I have?
and everything oh thank goodness I'm my shotgun okay my
sitcom is up oh she's back good job I'll shut it I'll shut
the door I don't know how to do that uh holy
out nice cover Alex that is that it you're not gonna do
anything okay that's over whoa what the reactors back on
track for a meltdown we got two feet away I'm sorry.
We're going another way around these buildings.
We really don't have time.
Uh-oh.
Okay, let's get in.
Things are like, oh my god, the fire is falling down.
That's crazy.
Yeah, it's don't seem so good.
Come on, Alex.
Let's go.
Yeah, don't think the city is okay.
Uh, debatable whether we are okay as well.
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
Wait, are they coming from both ends?
No.
We're
good.
Thank you.
Just a shotgun to the face.
Nothing does it better.
Excuse me, yeah?
Then a shotgun to the face.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, that's the that's the baby!
Uh-oh.
Wait, this doesn't look good.
Wait, do you see all the supplies?
Wait.
What's that beeping sound?
Get away from the doors.
Are we good?
Don't turn around!
Girl, your instincts, please.
Aren't you a...
Good work, Minto.
Thank you.
Uh.
Take that.
We don't need any more health.
All right.
Very good.
Um, is that...
Oh, it is.
Oh, awesome.
Wait, why did they give me all this stuff in the room?
I'm nervous.
Wait, I'm naivest.
Because they gave us all this stuff.
But there was only just a couple of guys.
Oh, naivest.
Okay.
smiley face yeah i know i know how these i know i know your
games
there's so much stuff here uh-oh okay that looks like a boss
area if i if i didn't know
Okay.
I heard a door open just now too.
Kind of funny.
Okay, I'm just gonna go for it.
Not the cyber truck!
I will control your...
I will control your children.
Oh shit!
Fuck you, man.
Oh, we got him!
We got him!
I could use some help, please!
Turn around!
Oh, is there a hole?
I got a car up.
Yes.
Wait, uh, wrong way.
Oh, I snap!
Ouch, oh.
Please.
Yeah, you do more work than me.
Holy cow!
Wait, where else are they coming from?
There's another one?
oh dang it i just i meant to reload my my dumb ass is too
trippy trigger happy one second i'll help you in like one
second oh oops that's not what i meant to do oh my god
nice okay we're going i'm
a professional at it now
Oh shit.
That should be good.
Are they coming from over the wall?
Hell.
Yeah, you get them.
You get them on that thing.
The music is cool.
That was too late.
Are we good?
Sorry, I'm just seeing what I have.
Okay.
Do we go?
She's looking at me like, um, what are you doing?
Oh, dang it.
I wonder if I can get him with my pistol.
How does he have the best aim in the world?
I'll take that.
all.
I did get him a few times, yeah.
Oh.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Oh.
What?
Who's that?
I wish I gave me more suit.
They give me more health, but not, wait, maybe up here.
There's more, maybe?
Please?
No?
Lucky.
Look at my bodyguard.
I just took out two guys with a grenade that they threw at
me.
What do you mean you're cooked?
You would survive the longest anyone ever has ever.
I...
Value life.
What was that?
Back up.
Did it go off?
Five stars.
Yeah, if there was...
Oh, it's one of these hoppers.
Is there a way to disable it?
Oh.
Like that.
Oh, oh, never mind.
Oh, wait, now it's my friend now, right?
Can I go over it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Green means good.
Yeah, green women, green women.
Oh man, another powered lock.
We love it.
It's behind.
Uh...
Oh.
I don't think it would be outside.
Yeah.
Green women.
Oh, I see it.
I blocked it.
I blocked it because I kind of dirty day area a little bit.
Okay, I got my pistol.
I wonder why.
Why is there only one of us going through vents?
Very curious to me.
Oh,
I didn't live.
What was I doing?
Oh.
Oh, this is what's supposed to happen.
Weird that when it's such that someone's not going through a
bit, right?
What was it?
What was in the other?
What was the ladder?
I didn't even get to go through the...
Who is...
That person was reduced to...
Reduced to jerky!
Dang, I should have not...
I should have like...
I reverse explored.
Um, alrighty now.
Oh, okay, I see...
I see this bench here.
Alright.
Um, if I don't make it...
I will tell my mom, I love her.
No, you guys do that.
And then I...
I'll go through that ladder that I didn't go through before.
Sorry.
Never mind, they won't let me.
The game is rude.
It's a really good thing that that doesn't touch the lasers
now, isn't it?
A really good thing.
Okay, we'll tell your mom we love her.
Okay.
Wait.
Wait a second.
Oh.
So close.
It can't, though, right?
It wouldn't do that.
Okay, parkour.
Watch this.
And watch this.
And...
Oh!
Wait, what?
Where do you...
go oh am
i in the water oh i'm in the water oh what's happening put
open it's oh it will i was
trying to blast the guy because he was body blocking me
oh my oops it's so funny
No survival instincts.
Yeah, no shit.
I'm dead.
Why would I have survival instincts if I'm dead?
I don't need to worry about this.
You have to worry about your survival.
Watch this.
Whoops.
I can't stop crying.
Yep, died.
We watched.
Nice!
Thank you.
Okay.
Man, I really want to...
Good look at that guy.
Watch this.
We watched, we laughed, clashing me down.
Okay.
I did it.
Go up, go up.
No.
Okay, we did it.
This is so messed up, actually.
This is...
Oh my god!
Where did that guy come from?
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
My man can't catch a break!
Oh, they hate him.
Oh, no!
Did he really kill that thing because he ate it, trying to
eat him and he hated it so much?
That's so funny.
Turkey man had a rough day.
I...
I believe it.
All right.
I saved.
I think I saved before, but we'll save again.
Oh.
All right.
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
Don't kill me.
Okay.
We'll save right here instead.
I'm so cute.
Oh.
All right.
To get through here is a little scary.
Oh, shoot.
Well, he's been on his way up.
Hi, I'm in Phantom and this is the Red Beryl Rodeo.
Welcome to Jackass!
Vinto.
Look, I was trying to lift it up, okay?
Can I just jump over it?
I don't think I can, though.
Oh, oops!
My bad.
This stream is the gift that keeps on giving.
Does crouch work?
No kidding.
No kidding!
I thought my head was too big.
Let's recharge.
But I need it to...
The secret tech.
Did it didn't blow up the wall?
Oh, gosh.
Ew, you're...
Oh, ah!
Where'd he go?
I know you're not dead.
Oh, the window has already exploded.
Yeah, I can tank anything.
Honestly.
You just tanked it?
I can tank anything.
It's my special skill.
Go there.
Oh,
is this a ladder that I was supposed to go up before?
No, kidding.
Eat that?
Aw, man.
Wait, no, this is not the ladder.
I'm still stuck in here.
Oh, wait, there's a ladder over there, though.
Um.
want to save because i did tank all of that and i feel
stupid a little bit
we passed this room i do remember
save okay oh it's a good thing i did that okay hold on watch
this nice see oh wait this is the okay yeah yeah yeah the
room i was in before Alright.
And, uh...
Oh.
Oh!
So fragile.
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
There we go.
I'm gonna miss Jerky Man too.
He was really cool.
Just wanted to make sure.
Beep.
Green?
Yeah.
That's a good boy.
I guess I have to go down here.
Oh yeah, there she is.
Does she even remember me?
Alex, you know who I am?
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
Do you remember me?
I'm Gordon.
How could we...
Wait, what was in this room?
Excuse me.
What was in this room?
I must know.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh, I'm back so soon?
You're real funny, Alex.
You're real funny, you know.
You're real funny about that.
I actually do need the...
I mean...
Don't you...
Forget about me.
Dun, dun, dun, dun.
I do need this, though.
I do need that, actually.
Okay, wait.
It's a good thing we saved that then.
Awesome.
Such a kidder.
You would not believe.
I bet he was jerky.
It was... Body blocked me.
You would not believe Alex.
You would not believe what I just went through.
Uh-oh.
Uh, back up.
Back up.
I think.
It didn't Take care of him?
That's kind of crazy, actually.
Wait, that's really crazy.
I don't think it can jump anymore.
I think we're safe.
Uh-huh.
More jerky.
Jerky everywhere.
Oh, it can?
You think so?
I think I should get it?
Oh, wait, but there's stuff here too.
Wait, I'm trying to get it.
Wait.
Green.
You can always use more ammo.
Very cool.
You can open those locker doors?
Oh my god!
I had no idea!
Thank you.
Too bad I'm full.
That looks like we're guys.
Gonna come through.
Uh oh.
Here we go again.
What's that mean?
I got you.
That's it?
Lucky.
Meow.
My little, my little mind was so helpful.
me oh the crossbow i'm starting to get everything back it's
so fun i lost it all and now we're we're back we're so bad
uh where do i plug this into excuse me excuse me wait hold
on watch out
Oh, uh-oh.
Oh, okay.
That, never mind.
That was for a...
Now we can snipe.
Yeah, exactly.
Um.
Where does it need to be plugged into?
Am I crazy?
Wait.
Try plugging it into Alex's head.
It's kind of stuck, actually.
She says, no, don't put the plug in my head.
No!
No, it doesn't belong there!
Gordon Freeman, I'm not a machine!
Please!
Please, please!
Why is it so dusty?
Was that it?
Wait, I'm trying to remember.
I can't!
No!
Oh!
We need to unplug it so that we can go through here!
Okay, just kidding.
Yes, yes.
Uh-oh.
Somebody's coming, I think.
Maybe not.
I watched him descend.
What do you mean I'm a menace?
Damn, that was so close.
Oh, wait, I can snipe now.
Ah!
Oh, shit.
Uh, run.
Run.
Yeah!
Ouch.
Are they getting?
Okay.
Alright.
We go.
Get them, boss.
Yeah.
We got them.
Ish.
Spiritors.
Is that what he just said?
Who is shooting?
If not the enemy.
Oh.
Whoa!
Guy with a...
Oh, my friends?
Barney?
Oh, friend!
Uh-oh.
Oh, shit.
I didn't mean to use that one.
They're all gone.
I got one.
You did.
You sure did, Barney?
Pretty sure that's him.
Yeah, we obliterated that guy.
I hate that it equips.
I hate that it equips when I don't mean to.
Um, there was a way to...
Oh, there it is.
Like that.
Okay, right click.
Oh, I thought there would be a ton of guys coming out.
I'm not gonna lie.
Ouch.
Sorry.
Thank you.
What the hell was that?
Oh!
Nah, just two guys.
Yeah, just...
Oh!
Hi!
Is you a Barney?
Who the hell are you?
Wait a second, I gotta go get my loot.
Oh, we can't go in there.
Of course we can't.
They have...
They have force fields everywhere.
Noise of the repel cord.
Yeah, I heard it.
Hi.
Are you gonna let us in or?
What are you still doing here?
Everyone should clear out of the city.
The Combine's not making it easy.
We're trying to get enough people together to force our way
through to the train station.
People are meeting up in a safe house nearby.
Can you take us there?
You bet.
Let's go.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm here to guard you.
I won't let you die.
Wait, oh, that's not a supply box.
This way.
Bentley.
Bjorn.
Ringling, it's me.
M to the I to the N to the T to the O.
Pinto!
Come on in, they said.
Previously, certain protein chains important to the process
of embryonic...
Your partner's daughter, right?
This is no longer the case for those so in class.
I can't hear.
He is so loud.
Which is to say, in layman's terms, you should give serious
consideration to doing your part for the revival of the
species.
We must know the most of the time we have, as it is by no
means certain how much time we have secured ourselves before
the Combine attempt to restore their dominion, as they
certainly shall.
Since this is, in fact, the first opportunity we have.
If anybody, if there are any volunteers that would like to
help repopulate the human race with me.
And in fact, I hope to institute a series of useful
bulletins in the days ahead.
However, for now we will have to content ourselves with some
relatively meager exposition.
The destabilization of the City 17 reactor has had
repercussions that were not entirely unexpected.
Although we hardly dared speak this hope ahead of time, the
destructive pulse forced a damper on the entire network of
linked systems.
Sorry, Doc.
I've fallen!
Oh!
What happened?
How did she do that?
Failed completely, as well as all communications systems
based on that technology.
In short, the Combine are completely cut off.
Combine forces currently stationed on Earth are now isolated
units.
You want that bald head?
However, this is most likely a temporary state of affairs.
I don't blame you.
Even the relatively tiny...
Bald...
It's not bronze.
and brain it's bald and brain forget about their evil plot
to take away to take away the wait forgot about their evil
plot to take away the freak there are many modified
post-human allies still remaining on earth who will be doing
their utmost to re-establish lines of communication and
supply all right let's go even so there is greater reason
for hope now than at any time in the past decade
to the what the hell let's find another way up who's there
oh did they shoot head crabs in oh my god I hate when they
do that
holy cow
Shinobi thank you so much for the five good day thank you
Oh, okay.
I thought he was...
I thought we had gotten him.
Are you...
I'm!
Oh,
shoot.
I don't know what I was thinking.
Yeah, thank you.
Help me out.
Yeah, get that guy.
I was thinking of just a normal heck of a rib.
We got him?
This is so classic.
Can I get back up there?
Alright, I'll get you, I'll get, oh, oh.
Damn it.
This has been Dr. Isaac Kleiner, formerly of Black Mesa, now
simply a citizen.
Like all of you, of Earth.
Citizen of...
Oh, they can hear, oh, I can hear them.
I blame Black Mesa.
How much for better living through science?
Dr. Kleiner says we can mate now.
What is this?
These labs are quite hot.
Dr. Kleiner said we can mate now.
Oh.
I hear something up there.
Oh, you're here!
What did I miss?
Residents of City 17.
What's up here?
Anything?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, just kidding.
Wait, I'm confused.
Wait, am I going down?
Wait, where am I going?
No, they confused me because they...
Okay, wait, where am I?
Yeah, I fell down, so we're trying to get up still.
Not here.
This is where the headcrabs are.
So we went through...
This door?
Death.
Oh my god, there's so much talking all the time.
Okay, there we go, there we are.
Oh!
I did not want that gun, but that's okay.
Dr. Kleiner's atzu.
For real!
He just won't stop talking.
Okay.
I thought he wouldn't see me for some reason, and that I
could, like, get him through the door.
but it didn't end up working that way that's okay
Alex I don't believe it how the hell did you get out of the
citadel oh my god not exactly sure oh please kiss me had
something to do with it but what about you Barney Barney I'm
doing okay just going crazy trying to oh wait oh Cal Gordon
I just followed again sorry thanks for the super chat wait a
second Gordon, Alex, I don't believe it.
How the hell did you get out of this window?
Fine, he's super chatting.
I don't know what it is yet, but it's important enough that
they've been hiding us the whole way here.
Well, that puts the pressure on.
Look, we got to get moving.
You guys know about the evacuation trains, right?
Yep.
Yeah, well, we've been planning to make a push on the train
station.
Yeah.
Now, it looks like we're going to have to cut a path through
every chicken ship Metrocop who's having second thoughts
about defending City 17.
Oh, my God.
If Gordon and I took a separate route, draw the combine away
from you wait that'll give you a chance to get the trains
filled up before we get there really well if you say so i
would like a say in this convert in this plan wait a second
i would like a say over the rooftops is a safe path to the
station safe asterisk everyone has been waiting we'll meet
you there sounds good let's go our hey Gordon, before you
go, I was getting tired of carrying this around.
Listen, I don't have any more of these, so try not to lose
this one, okay?
Oh my god, not only do we get our crowbar, but Barney!
Barney is the one who gives it to us!
We are so bad.
I'm running.
See you at the station, Barney.
I guess we go this way?
That's an enemy gunshot.
Surely it doesn't know we're in here.
Oh, sorry.
Watch out.
Watch this.
Alex, watch this.
you see that there's not a man in there
what's a Russian gunship doing in city 17 boss get down I'm
glad every time I say it exactly like that you guys know
what I'm referencing it's it's the way in Metal Gear Solid 5
Acelot will be like, Boss, get there.
That's an enemy gunship.
It's so funny.
He says it the same way.
Wait.
I'll go back to my shotgun.
Which way should we go?
Up or down?
Ouch!
Is it on me?
Oh,
there's a lot of them.
Oh, these guys are so nasty.
I was really hoping I get a twofer.
Ouch, is it on me?
Okay, when you make you sound like that, I sound dumb.
Okay, uh...
Uh-oh.
I think he's coming this way.
You think he...
Uh oh.
I think he's coming this way.
Ouch.
Where'd she go?
Alex?
What?
Oh.
How did you get over there?
Human shield.
She has higher health than I do.
Wait, I do want to check this though.
Oh, okay.
I'm so dumb.
Well, that's fine.
I needed to regain that anyway.
Okay, cool.
you shot her no I was shooting the thing obviously I was
shooting the guy the what did they call zombine does
you see that
it's a zombine watch this watch this
Oh, Gordon Freeman.
What did you say about me?
Oh, you think they could see me?
You think he saw me because my flashlight was on?
Alright.
Nope, nope.
Not yet.
I love this gun.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Okay.
Now I think we're good.
Oh.
It wants us to go down?
What?
But our safe way to the train station.
It wants us to go down!
Oh, man.
Look carefully.
Wait, look again?
It's...
It's the eye of Sauron.
Is that the wheel?
Oh!
Thank you.
What if I had gone down?
What if...
It would be so bad?
How would I get back up?
Oh, sorry.
Actually, I pushed my wheel.
Or my mouse.
Save it and try.
I think you die if you fall.
Really?
Hold on, I kind of want to see.
I don't think so, right?
Unless it's like...
There has to be, like, a way back in.
Wait, I was down here before?
Great.
There's, like, so much...
Actually, there's, like, so much stuff down here.
Oh, yeah, this is where I was!
Yeah, yeah, that's what I thought.
Oh, my God.
This seems like a soft lock.
Yeah, I think we reload.
I don't think it's...
I don't think they would soft lock it.
Because I'm sure there were plenty of people that thought
that they should...
Needed to jump down there, right?
Hey, a hospital.
Keep an eye out for medical supplies.
Okay.
Who's shooting?
Should we keep an eye out for anything else?
Oh
my god.
Oops.
I didn't even get that guy.
That's so lame.
I just bonked him.
Ouch.
Watch out, Alex.
Woo!
There's a...
Alex, keep down.
That's an enemy kind of shit.
Whoa.
Wait.
Oh, I can open this, can't I?
Yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Cool.
Okay.
Careful.
Is this guy dead?
I can't move.
You're in my way.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, fuck.
Oh, I'm shot gunning from far away.
Oh, she got him.
Kind of.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay, thank you.
Dang, I really thought those guys were dead.
They chiricked me, how could they?
Alright.
Oh, save anyway.
Ouch.
I tanked it.
I tanked it for you.
Alex, I tanked it for you!
I tanked it for you!
What was it?
Anything in the bathroom?
Were we for real?
I hear something.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're fine.
Let's keep going.
Skippy!
Barney would be impressed.
I think he would.
You know what I was just saying?
I'm going to go.
Oh.
Wait, there's a guy over there.
But he doesn't look like an enemy.
Oh.
I'm not crazy, right?
There was a guy standing right there.
Right.
There was a guy.
Oh,
are we boss fighting with...
Oh my god, the floor is so fragile.
Uh...
Oh shoot!
He really was here!
He was here!
I can't remember if I saved or not.
Where'd it go?
Where is he?
Ouch, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Major.
Oh my god, Alex, you scared the crap out of me.
I thought you were a guy.
I saw, like, the blue of her.
And I thought it was, like, uh, you know, the guy's eyes.
I don't think I'm going to be able to do this one first try,
but that's okay.
There's, like, no supplies here.
Alja...
Oh my god, I'm such an idiot!
Okay!
Oh, there he goes.
I saw it happen.
Ah!
I'm stuck!
Thanks for helping, Alex!
Thank you very much!
I had a pretty good... I have a pretty sweet spot right
there, so I think I'm gonna go back.
Oh my god, no.
Oh man.
I think I might have lost my spot.
Dang it.
I think I lost...
Nope.
No, I can get back.
Yeah.
Come on!
Oh, there he is.
Just keep looking out here.
We'll come back around.
Spot yet, yeah.
As long as he doesn't like come up here.
Woo!
It was such a good spot before.
Ouch.
Hey!
Okay, uh, maybe I need to...
Oh!
Wow!
Jesus, Gordon, you're a real terror.
That's not what you say to somebody who just saved your
life!
Maybe you should whack it with the crowbar just in case.
Good idea.
I'll do it again.
Oh god, not again.
Oh.
No way.
Wait, let me save.
Stop shooting me!
Hold
on, let me redo that.
I forgot that this had a grenade on it, too.
There we go.
Oh, Tupan no armor.
Okay.
Why, that went perfectly.
You think so?
Thank you for believing in me.
Thank you.
Truly, I would be terrified of the last thing I saw was a
phantom with a shotgun running towards me with a gun.
My war cry is vicious and not to be messed with.
That's right.
this guy a couple more times very cockroach cockroach again
did i grab more ammo okay we're full cool
holy cow wait did it just explode okay that's fine nice
Jumping bines Rip Matara No Rest in hell Rye Rye Matara Um,
okay I don't think we can I think I have to do this Uh,
watch out, Alex Good job So much for medical supplies.
Right, it was completely clear.
Now, you're pretty good with your...
She's really good with her, uh...
With her pistol, though.
I'd say.
Aw, man.
Unlike me.
10-shot Minto, that's what they call me.
Rest in peace, Matara.
She got hit by a bazooka.
Okay.
Rest in peace, my grandma.
Yeah, boy!
Thank you.
I don't know why I keep checking the bathrooms.
There's literally nothing.
Let's just go.
Ooh!
I
have a shotgun, too.
Oh, my God.
Oh, nice.
Are you gonna attack us?
Oh, he's confused.
Ouch.
Compulsive bathroom check, I can't help it.
Ouch!
You did not get them.
I believed in you.
And you really disappointed me.
Don't go there.
Who?
Did she shoot me?
What got me?
May I move?
Oh, nice.
Let's let them handle it.
The door got me!
Aggressive.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wow!
They're just shooting at nothing, actually.
Holy hell.
What got me this time?
Was it her?
Could have been.
Oh,
it does open.
Yeah,
me too.
You take care of it.
I don't want to do it.
Nice.
Oh.
You got him all?
Oh!
I got it.
Oh, excuse me.
Oh.
me.
That was sick.
All right.
Nice.
Good job.
The room was just bait.
It do be like that.
Ain't that just the way.
Maybe we shouldn't stick around to find out what's going on
there.
holy
okay fine oh my god of course what the hell is that oh no
it's this thing again oh wait uh I don't want to do it I
don't want to waste it on that oh my god we gotta take this
guy out though thank you ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch oh shit
I'm not okay wait I'm not okay
Set him on fire!
Oh my god.
Really?
Can he take care of him, please?
Yeah, thank you.
I wish he would go back to her pistol.
She keeps using the shotgun.
Oh, this is where we're going?
Oh, I thought we were going in here.
Hold on.
I don't...
Okay, I will save.
But only because I had a near-death experience.
Uh...
Oh, dang, I thought there would be more health.
Toxic head crimes are so menacing.
They are!
They suck!
They suck so bad.
Oh.
Clean...
Clean bathroom.
Well, not clean.
Uh, bright bathroom.
Alright.
I hear them.
I think I hear them below.
Which is the thing that shoots the orb.
Oh, this guy.
Okay.
We might need it in here.
I fear.
Yeah.
I hear so much going on in here.
I don't know.
It might not hit anything, but it could hit everything.
At least they can't kill you directly.
That's true.
Alright, let's go.
Oh!
Gordon!
Are you okay?
No.
I'll meet you up there.
Oh, don't send them down here.
Nasty.
It's always something, huh?
It's always something!
Back to my shotgun.
Okay, we gotta go find a thing so that we can turn on the
power to do the thing.
No breaks this episode.
No breaks any episode, honestly.
That's always just how Half-Life has been, though.
Alright, oh, can I get up here?
Yes.
Ew, we're so close to them.
Ew.
Oh, there's another one.
Okay.
Don't hide!
Wait, I actually can't see him now.
I just got it.
Okay, I got one.
Oh.
Alright.
Tubby Gordon at it again.
We're close to completing episode one.
Let's go!
Oh!
Okay, so the floor is lava.
How do they not, when they stick their little mounds in
there?
Oh, I guess they did die, huh?
They did die.
Um, what can I give them?
Do you want a crate?
There you go, there you go.
There you go.
Open that for me?
Wait.
Actually, I need to...
Can you do it again?
Wait, can you do it again?
He's literally rejecting it.
Can you do it again?
Wait, can you do it again?
Okay, cool.
Um, hmm.
I guess they did get electrocuted now, huh?
He don't want it.
I don't pick you either.
I don't want to have to worry about them while I figure out
this puzzle.
There we go.
Da-da.
Skull.
I legit don't know how to do this puzzle.
Well, that's why we're here to all figure it out together.
Don't you worry if you're like, I never knew how to finish
this puzzle.
We'll figure it out.
Together.
Somehow.
Just damage boost through it.
Hold on.
Let's save.
Ouch!
Oh, shoot.
I think I could have if I hadn't gotten got.
But there's no way for me to get these guys.
eyes.
Can I...
Barrel?
Barrel.
Barrel, you're my only hope.
Barrel!
Barrel, Barrel, you're my only hope.
Uh-huh.
The electricity might have killed you, but at least we
managed to avoid drowning yes indeed you can turn the power
off too you can
what okay that that is a world's a difference thank you very
much to whoever just told me that it was a I
was like what the heck is that in there
I can get it this time.
I'd like to get the supplies in there because if it's, like,
more suit, then that'd be nice.
Did I get it?
I made a noise, but I don't know if it was just out of...
out of fear.
Okay.
And then there's some more here.
Actually, let's, um...
Now we can...
Oh, sure?
It's all yours, buddy.
All yours.
Oh.
Oh, no, no, that's mine.
No, no, stop, stop, stop, stop, game, stop, game, stop,
game, stop.
Game, stop.
Where the players, players play.
What is the, what is GameStop slogan?
Okay.
Okay, actually, I think we do need this, like, kind of over
here.
It's in the game.
The game is...
Power to the players.
It's gaming time.
We game and go.
I'll get this guy at least.
You guys are such a pain in my butt.
You know that?
You know how much of a pain in my butt you are?
yeah throw it up throw it up i don't want to see it i don't
want to hear you anymore hashtag not sponsored definitely
not sponsored by gamestop can't say that i am sponsored by
gamestop gamestop we steal your best buy girl what's a best
buy girl I don't hear that guy over there anymore.
Maybe I did get him.
Let's try this.
Again?
Wait, actually before we do so.
I will go in here.
I didn't hear him, so I thought he was dead.
Okay.
That was... that was nasty.
That was so nasty.
Ah!
Did I kill him this time though?
Yes.
I think so.
That's you?
Alright.
We really just have to tank it, huh?
Like the damage.
Okay.
We have 99 health and an 80 suit, so I guess, um, could be
worse.
I mean, there are ways.
There are!
How?
Do I surf on the barrel?
There is a way here.
I don't think you ever need to tank damage in Half-Life.
I guess that's true, because that's just bad game design,
you know?
Ah.
Wait.
I have an idea.
Similar to the other puzzle.
Where we put it underneath.
Oh no, no, no, please.
Oh my god, that's probably fine though.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, my game.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Do you guys see my game lagging or is it just me?
I think I'm okay now.
Whoa, that was freaky.
Oh, it was lagging, okay.
Yeah, that was weird.
I'm still lagging a bit too.
Sorry about that, guys.
Alright, ikimasu.
Hoi!
Whoa!
Do I walk along- now I feel like I have to walk- I go along
the pipes here.
Yeah.
Where did those come from?
Where did they come from?
I'm wasting so much ammo on these guys.
That's fine.
This is fine.
Nice!
Oh, yeah, yeah, it's just pistol ammo.
Alright, cool.
We did it!
Wow, we didn't take any damage!
We gained?
Thank you guys for pushing me to figure out what the true
puzzle was.
What was that?
Oh, Alex!
I didn't forget, oh.
Alex!
Oh, oh, hello.
Sorry about leaving you alone down there, Gordon.
I got a bit swamped.
Okay, I, I'm okay, I believe you.
I see, you did all right without me.
Oh yeah, you can see these guys, right?
I took out every single, single one of them.
Oh, is this what you meant?
Good.
What?
Alex, what did you...
This is overkill.
Dr. Breen's private reserve.
You didn't need to topple the guy with the...
Oh, you didn't even cut off his legs!
Alex, what did you do?
What?
You know what?
It did give me a grenade, so I will partake.
Monk.
It didn't.
It didn't kill him.
Holy.
Loud.
Sorry.
Can you help?
Right click to throw at close range for the grenade.
Oh.
Did we get him?
I think we did.
That guy is so nasty.
Ugh.
Not a fan.
I want to get that thing, though.
Well, I guess I don't really...
Well, there's ammo there, too.
He has been gotten.
Watch this.
Oh, I got the house.
Well, at least.
Okay, well, that's fine.
Okay.
Oh, hello.
Oh, gosh.
Yeah, burn!
Burn!
Oh.
Get the other guy?
Now get the other one?
He walked right over to him.
Did you see that, Alex?
Wasn't that so funny?
Oh.
Holy shit.
All three are on her.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I might be done for her.
No, we're good.
We're fine.
Nope.
I aggroed him.
Sorry.
Woo!
Okay.
We're fine?
Whoop!
We're not fine.
Where did they come from?
Oh.
What the?
Thank you!
She really liked that one.
Are we good now?
Everything's fine?
Dr. Breen's private reserve?
Okay, cool.
Hold on.
Let me look around real quick.
Okay!
Okay.
Oh, health, really?
Nothing?
Okay.
We...
What are these?
Oh, flares!
Okay.
The way those things run always creep me out.
Yeah.
Something not nice about them, right?
Oh!
I'm in a hospital, is this?
He was, he was, he looked a little stiff before, but now
he's just chilling.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Oh!
He is fine.
Probably.
Excuse me.
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
Wow, I did nothing.
Is someone shooting?
Oh, watch out.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, how do I take care of these again?
Ah, just a little toasty.
He likes it, though.
He's, he's a, he's, he's grinning.
He's, he's a toaster.
Now you can't, he can't stop.
Grenades?
On these?
Watch out.
Oh, that's right.
Ow!
Okay.
Oh.
Hmm.
Oh, I have no power.
That's why I couldn't run.
I wonder if I could crossbow it.
Unless it gets stuck on the...
Yeah, I think it gets stuck on the...
Damn.
on the border the the barrier that's it
the easy to knock over turrets are protected they learned
they did i'm kind of proud of them
wait oh no i panicked shit oh my god wait hold on i'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna reload I'm gonna reload so we don't
waste ammo and we don't have that happen too that was stupid
okay okay that's fine this is fine now I know it's happening
now I know it's gonna happen okay geez Louise oh shoot nice
it's really nice having Alex here is like a second you know
she does good work I'd say We're...
Okay, she does good work.
Oh, they came from in there.
And there's more of them.
Did that get me?
I'm actually not sure.
Oh, there's more supplies in here.
Whoa!
Oh, holy cow.
We good?
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
Oh!
All the...
Oh, I thought that was a thing.
I thought that was a...
A ceiling sucker.
Oh!
All right, cool.
We're good!
Ish.
Asterisk?
Maybe.
Run.
Ouch!
Now they only shoot me.
Have you noticed that?
I think there's a little bit of a...
Something going on here.
Okay.
Oh wait, both of them are gone.
We'll keep you here.
And we'll keep you here.
Then we'll go inside.
What if we barrier back once we're in?
Then the things out there can't come.
Get us!
No?
Alright.
Sorry, Minto, but Gordon isn't as cute.
I guess not.
That must really be it, huh?
Just making sure you're working!
Are you working hard or are you hard?
Look at him!
Hardly working!
Wait, where did they go?
Oh, I guess when I pulled the plug!
Oh, the gen- okay, I see what happened.
That's funny.
Ah.
Yay!
I'm a slacking.
No slackers around here.
Wait, we actually made it.
Oh boy.
They're onto us.
Better find Barney and get moving.
Do you think this still has bullets still, you think?
Last chapter.
Yippee!
I can't tell.
Do you think this one doesn't?
Oh.
Oh, it's taking pictures of me.
That's awkward.
Get my best angle.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Sorry.
Oh no.
What could we have?
What could we need these for?
What?
I wonder.
What do I hear?
Oh, it's you oh wait Barney why how did you get here so fast
I thought you said it was a safe route to the train station
oh wait we were we that's right we were the ones who were
distractions that's right what are you looking at nice day
Hey Tram, thank you so much for the gifted.
Thank you.
Hi Barney.
Oh, am I leading you guys?
I don't think this war is ever gonna end.
I don't want your pessimism, okay?
Train maybe is this way.
Uh-oh.
What are you looking at?
Is the train over here?
Oh, is this...
Is this...
Rideable?
Everybody don't follow me.
I don't know where I'm going.
A lot of carrots.
Final stretch.
Yeah!
Hold on, thank you so much for the...
You have to thank you.
Oh no, this too... Wait, there's so much going on here.
where am I taking them it's very quiet to the exit oh you're
supposed to wait till everybody else is on board first oh
why are they gonna do that or well that wasn't so hard we
should have brought everyone over at once don't say that I
Take a hit.
Escort mission.
Get back, Doc.
I'm sure you want to help everyone else get the safety
first.
Am I waiting on this guy?
Is this guy gonna do something?
Oh, you've remembered that there's a trigger.
I'll have to go back and get more.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I get it now.
I didn't realize that this was the drop-off point.
Got it, got it.
Go back and get another group.
I'll stay here and guard the gate.
Oh.
Here another?
Hmm.
Soup.
Okay.
Escort mission.
Oh, is this terrible?
Or better save a lot?
Okay.
All right, I will save a lot.
Thank you for the warning.
Not that I don't already typically do that anyway, but yeah.
Good to know, anyway.
What are they doing?
Beep, beep.
This is my friend?
Yeah.
Not my friend.
That's sneaky.
That one's actually sneaky.
Holy cow.
I'm sure they dropped some I hear like I hear that me in the
back of my brain I can't tell if it's me or if they you know
okay I can't tell if it's me you citizens follow dr. Freeman
hi oh two of them we got this
that's me
I don't need your commentary please thank you alright
am I your therapist like what are we
when this is all over who am I kidding whoa oh gosh there's
more of them oh shoot maybe okay I don't think I can just
dilly dally I think I gotta Oh, damn it!
You, asshole.
Oh, more?
Okay.
Oh, hello.
Uh, let's go.
Wait.
Alright, let's go.
Now we gotta bounce.
Okay, come in here?
Yes, good, good.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Stand there!
Ouch.
I'm the one standing there.
Run!
Will they listen to me?
Ouch.
I'm tanking it.
At this point, I don't really care.
Okay, at least...
Yeah, I know!
Okay.
Was she helping?
Our PGMO is infinite.
You know what?
You're right.
You're so right.
Nice.
everybody thank you I was gonna heal but you did that for me
this guy's still going at it he's 1v1ing this this thing
okay okay all right we gotta get out of here yeah let's just
RPG everything because I Okay, I know I keep, like, saving,
but I just want to...
Okay, they're safe.
Go for another group.
How many groups do I have to do now?
Holy shit!
Sorry.
Yeah.
Yeah, kill him.
Two down.
He's stupid.
Wait, but I don't...
You know what?
Screw it.
Let Alex take care of him.
I'm gonna die, though.
I'm gonna die for real.
I need to take care of these guys.
Ah!
Dang it, I was reloading.
I didn't think he was so close.
Oh my god.
These guys are tanky.
Ah!
Can I have more, please?
Yeah, please have more.
Okay.
Are you my friend?
You are my friend.
Who's- oh, it's a sniper!
No way!
This is so mean!
Are you my friend?
Yeah.
I don't think that guy's my friend.
Actually, those two are not friend use the rocket oh you're
right I didn't even think about that you guys are so smart
how'd you know oh
I forgot to save again that's okay though we took we took a
ton of damage this last time so
go get more citizens Gordon okay
This is hard, you guys.
This is hard.
Let her take care of them.
You got this.
Thank you.
Okay, well, we came in with significantly less damage than
this last time.
So, honestly, already doing better.
Can I have that guy?
Friend.
That was close.
How did I take damage?
Did he shoot me?
Is that why?
I took so much damage.
Vital signs critical.
at what cost?
I can't direct it.
It's a heat directed thing, so I can't shoot.
I can't shoot unless I, like, direct it, you know?
So it's kind of...
Wait, right-click the rocket to disable tracking mode.
Well, how do I know if tracking mode is on or not?
Because it doesn't...
I've clicked it so many times now.
Does right-click disable the laser?
Oh, no.
I've clicked it.
It did not.
Okay.
The laser turns off.
No, it doesn't.
This game does not do that, apparently.
I think I'm... I think I'm gonna save, though.
Against my better judgment.
Against my better judgment, I saved.
Okay.
You are not friend.
Oh?
You are friend.
You are not friend.
But there we go.
Okay.
Alright.
Fantastic ass kicking dock.
Oh man.
No, there's four of you.
Okay.
Sometimes I dream about cheese.
Shouldn't we be doing something?
Oh, I had water in my mouth.
You smell that?
It's freedom.
Some people don't dream at all, so you know what?
This guy has it good.
She is.
Watch out.
Don't do that.
Don't look at me while you're shooting either.
Also, don't do that.
Stop that.
Get inside.
Don't look at me while you're trying to shoot.
You haven't hit a single one!
Miss ma'am!
Everybody in?
Everybody inside?
Don't go ahead of me.
Yeah, me too.
What just happened?
Oh.
Did I take whatever they were out?
The route changed.
Oh, you're right.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, yes.
I did notice that this was up.
I...
Okay, yeah.
Um...
Now, Alex, what have you been doing?
Drop!
Oh.
There we go.
Yes, everybody.
Hurry up, people.
Yeah, hurry up, people.
Wait, no way.
Come on.
I need you to drop down.
And you too.
Cheese!
Cheese, please!
Wait, is this cheese?
I can't.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, come on.
We've got you covered.
Thank you.
Go in there.
Alright.
Can you give me a health?
Health?
Okay.
Alright.
That's group three?
Can these open?
Not all of them.
Dang.
I could eat a horse.
Hoops it all.
Okay, they're safe.
Go for another group.
Okay.
Four or five more groups?
Bring another group of citizens, Gordon.
How many more groups?
Wait, two more groups.
That's a really big difference.
Okay, I'm going.
Wait, where do I go now?
Oh, this is one of those things.
Yeah, I'm just kidding.
Okay, I'm going.
Bossy.
Maybe she's getting him.
Okay.
My health.
My health is very cursed.
Yeah, take care of him.
Ow, my God.
He's gonna walk over here.
He's not gonna walk over here.
They said hold positions?
I can't tell where I hear them coming from.
Did they shoot my shotgun?
Oh, I'm gonna die, aren't I?
Oh, no, they did.
They died, not me.
Okay, yeah, I just accepted the death.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, geez.
Oh.
I lost some health, but...
Oh, okay.
Okay, I will.
Get rid of the APCs.
Can someone like refill this thing?
It'd be really appreciated.
What is an agent?
Thanks, Barney.
I will.
Did I save in here?
I don't think I did, did I?
I don't know.
Barney's really tanking these.
Oh my gosh.
I have no more ammo.
How many rockets can this thing shoot?
You saved at 100 HP?
I did?
I'll still try.
There's no guarantee, but, you know.
Holy shit.
Shoot.
Oh.
Ouch.
Oh my god!
This thing is insane!
It's not even that there's infinite ammo.
It's that they can just non-stop one at a time.
Like just pew, pew, pew, pew.
Holy cow.
All right, boy.
Oh my gosh!
Keep moving, play Doom.
That's all you needed to say.
Wait.
Hold on.
Let me redo.
You got him as I died.
Okay.
But how?
How are you supposed to...
Oh my god.
Oh, I think I got him.
Now that's the Gordon Freeman I know.
Can I have a med pack please?
Thank you.
Ugh.
Doomstraat.
Oh, I didn't know that we had another guy in here.
Is there someone?
I need...
Oh, I was gonna say I need health, bad!
Oh, thank goodness.
We're at...
Someone is in my way.
Maybe we're good.
Let's keep going, everybody.
We're not good.
Just keep running.
Don't look back.
They're not there.
Okay.
My team?
My team, you need to follow.
Team, you need to get inside.
Well, I regret not taking those guys out, I wonder.
I wonder.
I'm gonna use this thing.
Yeah, I have mines covering me.
You're so right.
Alright, team.
Let's go.
I'm pretty sure this wasn't part of the plan.
I've successfully deduced that this was not how this was
supposed to go.
Alright, jump down.
You first.
Poor me.
Monkey see, monkey do.
Come on.
Come down.
Thank you.
Run!
That was a close one.
Okay.
More?
Just one more group?
Is that it?
So this one will be the toughest, toughest of them all.
The super tough one.
You gotta get Barney.
You're so right.
Thank you.
We're ready for another group of citizens.
Okay.
I'm not.
When do I get to say in this?
When do I get a say in this?
We need Barney.
Barney will probably do an amazing job helping out though on
the way here.
It's quiet.
Oh.
Wait.
Ow!
What did I take damage from?
I think they shot me.
Oh!
Maybe.
Maybe that's okay.
Good job, mines.
Yeah.
Good job, my mines.
Oh!
What were they doing in there?
Uh, wait, hold on.
Hold on, I want to redo.
I want to redo.
God!
How could I miss?
Alright.
Um...
Maybe this.
Or...
Stop it!
Damn.
That was so close.
Wait!
All right.
I'm being like careful about it, but I think we just need to
kind of...
Ah, nice.
So close.
I can get him.
No!
You bastard!
Oh, why can't I get him?
There we go.
My goodness.
Anyway.
To the trains, people.
We'll make sure you get there safe and safe.
Okay.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Let's just run.
Go for it!
I also am reloading.
So, I don't know what you want me to do, man.
Okay, let's just go.
Just go!
Don't worry about- Oh, I forgot to reload.
Wait.
I forgot to get Barabo.
Uh, one second.
One second, everybody.
Um, I- I messed up.
Sorry.
One second.
Okay.
Don't follow me.
Get back inside.
Everybody in.
You two.
That is including both of you.
Thanks.
Thank you.
All right.
That could have gone better, but, uh...
Wait.
I'm, like, standing in the middle of the wave.
I'm stuck.
Good job, Arnie.
Where are you shooting?
Got to reload.
Oh, I'm not on top.
of the thing.
Alright, don't push me off.
Thank you!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh!
Ouch!
Watch where you're shooting that thing!
Everybody?
Come on!
Yep, there we go.
We're running!
We're...
Hurry up, people!
Yeah, hurry up, people!
Come, can you heal me?
Actually?
Can you heal me?
Take this med kit.
Thanks.
Okay, cool.
Yay!
Yay?
What if I went through?
Yay!
Woohoo!
Yeah.
Yay.
You guys coming?
Go on, Barney.
They're not after you.
Gordon and I will draw their attention while you get the
others away from here.
What?
I thought we needed to leave!
The place is about to blow up.
What are we doing?
What do you mean?
Get on the train!
She's shuffling behind me?
And we're walking.
Take care of yourselves.
I see you out there.
I hate you, Alex.
Good luck.
Bye, Barney.
Hey, Barney.
Don't make me stay with her.
Please, she is trying to kill me.
Barney, I think she's working for them because what do you
mean that I can't go with you.
I'll see you when I see you.
Look at she just stands there with a smile on her face!
Ew!
Ahhhh!
Head start on the next train.
No time to lose.
Right.
No time to lose, which means you could crouch.
Thank you.
She's trying to kill me.
She called that guy over.
Oh, that's a fence.
You know what?
That's fine.
That's a great place to restart from.
Can I go in here?
Oh, I can.
Oh, can you see me?
Wait, I can't see them.
It's so dark.
Surely they're dead.
Of course not.
Alex is trying to get us killed.
Realist, real, my actual theory.
My actual real theory here.
Okay.
Re-re-power.
Go, go, go.
Ouch!
I'm still- Oh, it's a fence!
Yeah, shoot the barrel.
Oops.
Shoot the barrel.
Okay, I don't think it's a...
Okay.
Hmm.
It's so dark.
Okay.
Did he blow up another hole?
Another way to go?
Um, I don't think...
I don't think so.
Yeah, I don't think that's an explosive barrel.
We got God.
Here we go.
Wow!
I still say I see it when I see it to this day because of
Barney.
Really?
I just say that because it's a cool thing to say, but it is
a very, it's a The nice Barneyism.
Thank you.
I'm using this thinking of you, Barney.
I'm just scoping the area.
How did he see me?
Oh, you know what?
I'm not gonna...
Oh, my God.
It's because I didn't have enough power.
Dang it!
This is fine.
Okay, all right.
Okay.
Let's save here.
All right.
Definitely feels like we're in the home stretch.
Just, you know.
Can I RPG it from here?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh geez.
Nice.
I'm out though.
That's pretty unfortunate.
I'm just gonna shoot him.
I don't know if that did anything.
Not enough ammo.
Yeah, unfortunately.
That's okay.
I really need him to leave though.
Hmm.
Don't bother.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Is he still there?
Oh my god.
Leave!
Okay, I'm just gonna go for it.
Wait!
What's blowing up?
No!
No, not on me!
Not on me!
I just healed.
Don't do that.
Okay.
Oh, I see more of them.
Wait, no.
There we go.
Let's do that again.
I didn't see that thing.
Oops.
Oh, that's not my grab gun.
Straight into the hopper.
All right.
Can't I grab them?
Okay, you're my friend, though.
We're buddies.
From where?
From behind?
Woo-lo-lo-lo-lo.
Yeah, woo-lo-lo.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
some dang supplies here, please.
Ouch,
ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I thought I was gonna smush me in here.
Oh, he's trying.
He's trying.
I can't see, though.
That's the issue.
Oh, ouch.
Okay, okay.
I'm trying.
I can't get out.
Actually, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck, actually.
It's okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, where am I supposed to go here?
There we go.
Yeah, take them out!
Okay.
Oh!
Thank you.
Okay.
Get crushed.
You're my friend.
Oops.
My friend!
I'll never forget you!
Okay, I should save here.
Hold on.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm just gonna run for it.
Yikes.
My friend!
My friend.
Friend real?
Um.
Oh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
You can't have stuff here and then not let me get it.
Like, that's so mean.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, up there.
Oh, geez.
Ow!
I'm checking if there's anything over here.
Does it appear to be?
Hey, how am I supposed to...
Just tank it on the way up?
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Oh, okay.
It's time.
Does this one break?
Ouch, ouch, maybe.
Shoot.
Oh, I only just got him this one time!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay, okay.
Amazing aiming.
I don't have my base!
Oh!
Wait, take him down!
Yeah!
Oh, it's so nice that they're on the ground, too, so that
you could just, like, run over them.
Yeah!
Sure, I'll save.
Ladder.
Oops.
Oh, okay.
We didn't take any damage.
Oh, thank you.
You were trying to kill me.
Don't even lie.
Don't lie to me.
Go on the train, Gordon.
There's no bombs on this train.
It's perfectly safe.
I'm right behind you, Gordon.
Here we go.
We did it, Gordon.
Is this it?
Is this our ride into the sunset?
Here we go.
We did it, Gordon.
Oh, sorry.
I was like, what's that red dot?
Escape from City 17!
Don't worry about that, but...
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, the transmission's going out.
Is it just like...
Is it just...
Spraying rockets everywhere?
Woo!
Whoa!
Psychic baby.
Defeat the baby in episode two.
We have to beat the baby in episode two.
GG's!
We did episode one!
Half-Life two.
Yahoo!
The ending is so bleak.
At least in...
The ending of Half-Life 2.
You felt like you beat something and did something.
But...
In this it's just like, oh no.
Yeah, I had to be continued in episode 2.
Oh man.
Just five hours, not bad for a first try.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm pretty slow at these types of games too because I like
take my time and I'm...
Walk around and I do, I'm cautious.
But yeah, that's it.
I wonder if the title screen changes.
Oh, who the hell are you?
Where's my bald man?
Where's my...
Huh?
Oh, Gordon!
No!
This is bald.
than anyone can bear but we will go serve here
we're done running this is our chance to take back our world
next time on half life episode seven time
those remind me of those dogs the um like the dog robot
thing Booty shot, booty shot.
Yay!
Oh, it did change.
Oh.
My game froze.
Oh, there it is.
Gnome alone.
If you are reading this achievement, Gabe Newell was
actually dot, dot, dot.
Half-Life 2, episode 2.
Done, done, done.
Episode 2, and then...
I would like to play the VR game, but one, it's VR, and
two...
My VR headset has been not working properly recently, so...
Might have to get a whole new one.
And this one was very expensive, so I...
I mean, I got it a long time ago, but...
Still was very expensive!
It's so scary in VR.
I believe it.
I think I will like fall over and knock my head.
Like, I'll go back to heaven or something.
Look at the membership!
Good job, Minto.
That was a lie.
Short story to decompress.
Mike Tyson came up in a trivia game at the Normie Party.
And I blurted out, eating blank blanks.
Oh, why would you say that?
Who are you and what have you done with my Oshi who claims
to not be able to play this game?
Well, it's been a long time.
It was a long time.
This wasn't so bad, though, honestly.
We've had much worse situations of half-lifeism, so.
This was okay.
Mint, are you streaming on any other platforms right now?
You know, it's really funny you mention that, because
actually...
I thought, what if I do want to stream on Twitch?
Like, dual stream.
Of course, doc, you won't.
Don't say, Barney, no!
Wait, was that the last time we see Barney ever?
That's so sad.
Try Princess, thank you so much for the, don't know.
But YouTube would still be my main, 100%.
But I was just like, I don't know, what if I wanna like, you
know, kind of expand my audience.
Expand my reach a little bit.
little bit.
But it also seems like a lot of work to set up because I
have nothing set up so.
Now do the one bullet challenge.
One more time.
It's not hurt to test the waters.
I guess not.
I mean, I know there's always, there's some people that
like, you know, watch Twitch more than YouTube.
So, I don't know.
I'm so comfortable.
I've never been on Twitch before.
I'm so used to YouTube.
Like, I know some streamers that do a stream and they only
look at one chat.
Like, they'll look at their Twitch chat only.
I think I would be the opposite.
I think I would stream and only look at YouTube chat.
Too many ads for my taste.
Oh yeah, I agree.
I agree.
I'd go to try and watch my friends, and I'm like, man,
there's so many ads.
And then I'll get, like, five minutes into the stream, and
it'll be five more minutes of ads.
It's so annoying!
Unskippable Twitch ads.
Watching Twitch VODs on Twitch is a pain.
Why?
Where did that come from?
Hello?
Thank you.
Huh?
Thank you, but also.
What?
Thank you for the very, very, very big dono.
Thank you so much.
Holy cow.
I don't know.
Why did that happen?
I have no idea, but oh my gosh.
VR headset finds...
No!
I...
I'm just gonna keep trying to figure it out.
my current one because if I if it doesn't work my current
one it's just a
paperweight oh my gosh thank you very much though thank you
very I'm I'm worried
but thank you so Dargo thank you so much as well well done
Freeman God I love how they leave insane escort missions to
the physicist.
Not suspicious at all to Alex volunteer you for everything.
May your night be magnificent and your dreams be full of
delicious mac and cheese.
That's like a plane ticket.
Is that our savior gave Nuel?
How was your yacht?
Oh my gosh.
Wait for the steam frame.
I am very curious about it.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm But, oh, man.
Gabin himself.
Gabin Nuo.
Well, thank you guys for helping me out with Half-Life 2
Episode 1.
I want to do Episode 2 sooner than later.
I worry, though, about my potato PC and how I will look.
Because I've been lagging this entire time for some reason.
I'm going to quit the game and see if it fixes it.
No.
I'm still lagging, aren't I?
I'm still lagging.
Why?
I have nothing open.
Hmm.
I think I want cheese.
I think I want some cheese.
Sometimes I dream of cheese.
Firefox But I exited out Most of my times I recommend you
play Both Entropy Zero And Entropy Zero 2 Both Half-Life
mods That are amazing stories That weave themselves into the
canon Oh, maybe Sometime Thank you, Michael Thank you for
the Silver Tent Why?
Weird Congrats on painting episode 1.
This episode is a bit rough.
We still did very well.
Two is a lot nicer though.
Is it really?
I didn't feel like it was so rough.
I do feel like these games kind of... These games kind of
feel like... I don't know.
I understand that like you have to make the game longer.
You can't just make it where it's like... Where... How do
you say?
You can't just have it where you need to get to point B and
you immediately...
get to point B very easily.
You know what I mean?
Like, you have to have, like, a, the whole, oh, no, the
floor collapsed, and you got separated, and now you got to
do another puzzle, and this and that.
But sometimes I dream of minto and cheese.
Together?
Minto and cheese.
You're not lagging, you're just ahead of your time.
Thank you for 22 votes.
Dr. Big sausage.
Cheese and Minto together.
Guys, just one month until my new outfit.
Isn't that so exciting?
Sorry, I couldn't hold it in.
Yippee!
Wahoo!
What a news drop.
Well, you guys just stayed until the end.
And so I feel like I should tell you something, fun,
exciting.
But I am going to go now.
And I'm going to go eat dinner.
Stream ended up being a little longer than I expected.
But that's A-OK.
That is 100% OK.
Ah, gee, thank you so much for the 50.
Tonko too.
Welcome back.
Why don't my tongue?
Phil, I have played Fear.
the first one i don't i don't remember playing the second
one i did play though i liked it a lot yeah yeah i did like
it episode two will be a bit shorter when you do that oh
cool my tongue oh
Thanks for sharing me, Minda.
I'll be getting something tasty to eat.
Thank you, school marketer.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm like, it's like, I'm like low FPS.
Okay, I'm going now.
Sorry that chat was not on screen for, like, the whole time.
It almost felt like a...
Like, one of my pre-recorded.
Then...
A stream, you know?
But I still saw you, guys.
I still saw you.
Let's see if there's anybody to raid.
Tomorrow is a very important day.
Den Setzu's...
We're celebrating our six-month anniversary, and we have
some cool stuff to...
To talk about.
Oh, Vicky!
singing for six months okay we will raid the vicky um who is
singing for our six month anniversary i've been wondering i
know like i feel like vicky and phoebe both do like weekly
weekly karaoke like theme stuff and i've been thinking i was
like maybe if i do like weekly karaoke if i make them
shorter would you guys be interested in that I feel like I
try to give myself some time.
We love your voice.
Maybe I can do like a weekly theme thing.
It won't be so many songs that I usually do.
Usually I do like 20 songs or more.
But I don't think it would be bad for my voice.
I feel like I run out of songs.
I fear I run out of songs 2 hour Yapp, 1 hour karaoke That's
what Vicky does
Yeah Darko, thank you for the don't know Nine Thank you Next
week's gonna be so exciting Because there's so many video
games events Are you interested?
Oh, I will be doing a watch-along of Summer Games Fest But
also Oh Yes, I am excited.
Yes, I am very excited.
I'm keeping my mouth shut.
But I do have a karaoke next week.
Anyway, so I will be doing karaoke next week.
Yes.
Otsubito everybody!
Thank you for Half-Life.
I almost said Half-Life 3.
Half-Life 2.
Wow.
Yeah.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
Otsumito, otsumito, otsumito, otsumito, otsumito, otsumito,
otsumito, otsumito.
Itta, oh, I gotta set up the redirect.
Itta-
la la la la la la la la
la I know I ditched it sorry sorry if I made you go on wait
why won't it let me redirect nothing is loading oh there we
go I think my computer is dying I'll shut it down tonight
why is nothing loading huh YouTube oh there it is Victoria
Roman okay bye bye See you, bye-bye.
For real.